Elon Musk has just I don't know how you
described this nuked the culture war and
it's really exposed some rather Shady
dealings which I find particularly
interesting notably a Saudi Prince is
rejecting the buyout offer because
they're one of the biggest investors
saying no no Twitter is worth more even
though most reporting shows that Twitter
is failing stagnant growth and it was
failing years ago Trump is the only
reason as far as I know that it started
to come back so why are these companies
so interested on retaining this power
Elon Musk is no longer the largest
shareholder Vanguard just bought more
shares and it seems like they're not
going to go for the buyout either my
opinion
you know the Saudi Prince is right
Twitter is more valuable than 54.20 per
share it's the political influence you
wield when you silence those who
disagree with you we've talked about
this before and I think this may play a
role naturally you have many Twitter
employees freaking out the media is
freaking out but Elon Musk ain't backing
down he's actually put them in a
difficult position because if they go
against the will of the majority of the
shareholders they're violating their
their fiduciary responsibility and it
opens them up to liability so this may
be one of the most epic and craziest
moments in the culture War we definitely
got to talk about that and I gotta tell
you man almost there's just too much to
go through because this is huge but we
do have the RNC pulling out of the
commission on presidential debates which
is also equally massive and a bunch of
stories about abortion being banned
which is seemingly just escalating and
of course many on the left are freaking
out we'll get into all that joining us
to today is the Intrepid Duo Smokey Mike
and the god king yeah who's who's who
who's first like billing you Jeremy well
smoking Mike gets First Billing because
when one is known as the god king they
they don't need they don't care about
things like that how do you follow a god
well who wants Michael go for it who are
you oh well I'm Smokey Mike I'm a
well-known guitarist and sitar player
and uh 1970s rock icon so it's good to
be here I do in my uh free time I have a
show called The Michael Knowles show at
the daily wire uh which is fun it's kind
of like a little aperture side project
not your passion project but it's not
yeah I mean the way I pay the bills is
with my acoustic guitar and my
psychedelic uh cool licks in all
seriousness uh maybe people don't know
you were on uh I don't know if it was
last time but you actually played a song
about your book for our members only so
I did hey you know I really have to
thank you guys because seriously I go on
Tim's show I come on the the podcast and
all of a sudden everyone in the super
chats starts plugging my book and I
think one of the main reasons that book
hit number one nationally is because
your listeners Tim were so relentless
about promoting this book which is why
I'm so happy to say paperbacks out in
June baby let's do it speechless what's
it called again
but actually I think they were trolling
me because what they would do is they
would start the super chat now get into
reading it and then it would devolve
into promoting
they got me but it helped so you know it
did great job guys keep it up June 2022
really appreciate it it's a great
gorilla PR we do have the god king
himself but small G right lowercase G
lowercase k uh I am the man to whom
Michael Knowles owes everything
except apparently the success of his
last book
uh yeah I'm the co-founder co-ceo of the
daily wire and uh also 70s rock icon for
those who don't know uh Smokey Mike and
the god king legendary uh performance at
the Ryman Auditorium last year how how
will we ever top it uh and the answer is
we don't we don't know I have an idea
I'm on board
Let's uh the garden the garden Madison
Square Garden because we've already
played the mother Church of country
music so you're saying that would have
to be the elevation yeah I suppose yeah
I mean I don't know how you pull off
filling out was it 60 000 cedar or
something oh that's easy no that's easy
it's like this guy doesn't even know a
good joke yeah yeah I don't know that
the garden that's easy but it's like you
know you got to get on a plane put on
the dumb masks they just extended that
another two weeks ago we got to work out
wait well hold on you don't have a
private jet
we got a 70s rock icon himself flies
well after what happened to Skynyrd we
said you know only commercial from now
what we said Is Only commercial for
Smokey Mike did we mention uh your name
Jeremy boring oh yeah my name is Jeremy
there may be you know somebody's
listening and it's like
all right we also got Sheamus Sheamus
cogle and I were on a YouTube channel
called Freedom Tunes we just released
the cartoon today very happy with it
very excited about it it's about groomer
teachers you guys are gonna love it and
guess what we are at 796
000 subscribers let's get to 800 000. we
can do it go over there hit the
Subscribe button we just released one of
our best videos ever you guys are gonna
love it Ian Crossing up in the house
what's up dudes uh I'm just a wild
animal and I'm happy to get rolling so
let's go awesome
Michael and Jeremy both back within
relatively short order so let's get this
party started before we get started head
over to timcast.com become a member if
you would like to support our work and
all of our Fierce and independent
journalists as a member you'll get
access to exclusive segments of this
show Monday through Thursday at 8pm and
guys you made all this possible we are
eternally grateful for your support and
we look forward to challenging the
system I used to say you know don't
forget to smash the like button
subscribe to this Channel and share this
show with your friends uh and the reason
I would say that is because if everybody
listening shared this we'd be bigger
than CNN well we're bigger than CNN plus
yeah so I don't know what else to say
other than we did it guys thank you all
so much because uh granted I think the
real issue is that CNN plus is just in
the gutter but uh you know good job no
what a great business strategy they're
like no one's watching our Network let's
make them pay for it
let's let's talk about this is I don't
even know how to begin with this story
because we just got so much going on
with the Elon Musk nuclear bomb on
Twitter
so as many of you may have heard Elon
Musk this morning announces he wants a a
full buyout 100 of the platform at 54.20
full disclosure I own 22 shares of the
company not a whole lot I would like to
see Elon Musk fix it and if that means
being bought out and getting rid of all
the shits I'm fine with that Elon Musk
is right about a lot of the problems the
top 10 users barely any of them tweet
anymore several haven't even tweeted
this year but something strange is
happening even though 54.20 is above
market rate it's a premium on the rate
of the the value of the shares and even
though Elon Musk is saying if he can't
affect positive change he might actually
sell off his CRS which would be
detrimental to the company
these powerful interests don't want to
sell I wonder why that is so here's the
first story we have in this because what
we're seeing is Elon Musk exposed what
appears to be some kind of shady
dealings Cameron Winklevoss says Twitter
is considering a poison pill to thwart
Elon musk's offer they would rather
self-immolate than give up their
censorship programs this shows you how
deeply committed they are to orwellian
control of the narratives and Global
discourse scary Elon Musk responds if
the current Twitter board takes actions
contrary to the shareholder interests
they would be breaching their fiduciary
duty the liability they would thereby
assume would be Titanic in scale what a
freaking stud it's just great the thing
that's most inspiring about this is
generally speaking Mo Money Mo Problems
right they're generally speaking we were
talking about this a little earlier as
people get money and get and influence
and power they they just they get timid
they get risk-averse and this guy is
gambling 41 billion million dollars on a
really important politically significant
troll I I think it's more than that
though you know he called The Babylon B
when they got suspended and the story
apparently as he said did you guys
really get suspended over this joke they
said yes and he goes I might have to buy
Twitter well also I think wow I mean
sorry just Elon Musk has got let I'll
put this way he's got 280 billion
dollars towards his net worth
if you had 280 bucks
and someone was like Hey this really
important thing is 50 bucks
you know you might be like yeah it's 50
bucks it's a lot but you know for him
well it's even better than that because
it's not as though it has no value so he
buys it for 50 bucks which he's not
going to have to do I think his actual
plan is offer them 50 bucks they're
going to say no he sells off his 9.2
percent he crashes the price of their
stocks now he comes in and buys it for
20 bucks takes it private fixes it
relists it on uh the New York Stock
Exchange a 12 18 months later doubles
his money so he gets to both uh do the
greatest probably social good for free
speech that anyone's Done In Our
Lifetime and probably double his cash on
the whole on the whole Affair yeah and I
also want to say when Twitter is
threatening to self-immolate and destroy
their company we have to take that
seriously because we've seen them do it
before like we know they're capable of
it Twitter yeah I'm just completely
destroying any value within their own
company my understanding is that before
2016 Twitter was losing users they had
changed their their metric for how they
calculated users from like there's
something like daily active to monthly
active so that you know because the
average person was using the platform
less they said okay well if they use it
once in the month then but it's been a
while so you got to fact check man that
one because I'm tracking that as much
but when I see this idea that Twitter
would self-emulate I'm like yeah because
I think the real issue for these
investors is power political power it's
more valuable than cash well and it it
is political that's the word we have to
use we you know we we always make fun of
this sort of build your own Twitter
build your own Google uh no they're in
sconstant power there was a time at the
beginning of social media when there was
competition we're way past that they've
exploited legal liability protections
they've teamed up with the government
and they've defrauded their users so
they're we're stuck with these guys so
now there's this third option which is
don't build your own Twitter just buy
your own Twitter and uh you know when we
talk about political power we usually
think about the government
we live in a republic in a republic you
govern yourself with speech you engage
in speech in the Public Square if some
Bozo in Silicon Valley is controlling
all the speech in the Republic and
censoring very important people in that
Republic you don't have free speech you
don't have a republic it's the most
important thing for our form of
government in years yeah there's an
important you know this term fiduciary
duty maybe not common to everyone who's
listening essentially what it means is
if if you are in a position of
responsibility for someone else's
investment then you have an illegal
obligation not just a moral but a legal
obligation to put their interests ahead
of your own interests and in publicly
traded companies this typically means
the executives and it means the board of
directors these are people who because
they represent in a sort of lowercase r
republican sense they represent
the average investor the retail investor
they have obligations the our friend
Vivek ramaswamy I think is so good about
this he talks about these companies you
know part of the story is that today
Vanguard took an outside stake in
Twitter so that they would actually be
the biggest shareholder and Elon would
no longer be the number one shareholder
Vanguard along with BlackRock and one
other State Street yeah yes
they own 22 trillion dollars worth of
the S P 500 worth of the top 500 uh
companies that are traded on the on the
stock exchange
what they are essentially is using your
money money from your 401k from your
Roth IRA money from your your pension
account they're using your money to
amass power for themselves to act
against your interests and I think Vivek
rightly points out it's actually
probably the greatest uh abuse of
fiduciary responsibility in all of human
history and I think that's part of what
Elon is I mean very clearly up against
he's up against the you say these deeply
entrenched uh powers that be or these
deeply entrenched Powers against Free
Speech it's literally three entities so
uh the daily wire you know you're
launching kids content are you
insinuating you're going to launch
Financial investment and holdings
companies to challenge this machine
there is nothing that we will not do
I'm just I'm imagining it's like you
know 2070 and people are like oh I got
to run to the Daily wire to cash my
check when you're out can you go to the
Daily wire to pick up a a large pizza
yeah yeah and then uh I'm gonna but I'm
gonna stop at the daily wire for to fill
up my tank before I go meanwhile down in
the Caribbean on an island called God
kingia I mean Ben has been offering me
payday loans since I started at the
company 50 points on the yeah if they
were to uh refuse this buyout and then
maybe do their investors wrong what
could they expect what kind of reprisal
well I think that heretofore none it's
never occurred to any of them that they
could be held responsible and I think
what this is the of all the tweets that
Elon Musk has put out in the last
several weeks about Twitter this is the
most interesting one because he's
essentially saying I am one of the
people they have a fiduciary duty too by
not joining the board Elon did not Place
himself in a position of fiduciary
responsibility which leaves him with the
with the actual legal right to act
against the financial interest Twitter
and I think what he's telling them is I
will personally sue them out of
existence if they violate their
fiduciary responsibilities but it's a
lie you know I mentioned the the Trump
thing the platform dying because when
Trump joins the platform goes nuts all
of a sudden people have a reason to use
it and Beyond it Alex Jones for instance
they have banned people to the point of
irrelevancy it's not fun anymore yeah I
stopped taking the platform seriously I
pose such absurd nonsense half the time
but back when there was a 1 million
followers on the platform it's weird to
me that's weird to me too I posted a
hairless rabbit once and I'm like why
are people following me but they do and
it's fine I just maybe that's it maybe
the irreverence and the uh you know the
the absurdity is something worth
following but my view is I used to use
this platform as a utility for
journalism right and now because of how
how nuclear how radioactive the platform
has become how awful it is it's it's
effectively worthless but I think maybe
Twitter realized what or I should say
assume that a lot of media companies did
that culture war is money as much as the
left likes to accuse any one of us of
being grifters yeah the left has been
doing what's called mission-driven
storytelling long before any
conservative right-wing or libertarian
person figured out what was going on all
of these digital media companies in the
early 2010s realized if we get political
we make money and then they have the
nerve to call everybody else grifter
here's the thing that's fine you know
obviously at the daily wire we we have a
point of view we have a series of biases
but we own those biases if you look at
the tradition of Journalism in America
you know the the Tennessee newspaper
used to be called the Tennessee Democrat
if you go back to the time of of the
earliest presidential elections John
Adams and Thomas Jefferson you know they
they wouldn't run for office they would
have looked down on that instead they
they owned and and marshaled newspapers
to actually be their political
instruments that's always been the
history of Journalism in this country
until the post work consensus and then
we came up with this absurd notion of
like objective journalism which
which is a paradoxical kind of concept
in and of itself I think it's very good
that the New York Times is so far left
it's very bad that the New York Times
won't just admit and own their biases
right if they would just tell us yes
we're on the left and that gives you
know that gives you uh a series of
expectations when you read our content
doesn't mean that we're gonna that it's
okay to be completely polemical or you
know to actually be propaganda Outlets
you should tell the truth but you should
let us know from what point of view
you're telling that I I agree except the
issue is when big Tech platforms Embrace
that well but again if Twitter would own
its biases if YouTube would own its
biases that would actually create a
market for Alternatives but the problem
is that they lie about their biases I I
disagree I think conservatives know
Twitter hates them and what do you do
parlor gab mines getter yeah no one's
going there because there are only two
reasons to be on Twitter and they they
matter Twitter is the smallest big Tech
platform it's why Elon can make this
kind of play on even though he's the
richest man in the world still takes a
lot for one guy to take down a big Tech
platform there are two reasons to be on
Twitter one is to get into fights with
celebrities it's super fun it's great
anyone can do it the celebrities fight
that's the one reason the second reason
is because it sets the news cycle so not
a lot of people actually use Twitter and
they never really have but all the right
people do all the right people do and so
it's it look I'll own it that's how I
write a lot of my shows I see what's
trending on Twitter right it's and it's
how a lot of news articles are written
now and all of the blue check journals
are on there and so if you can control
the narrative on Twitter you're really
controlling the narrative throughout
most of the mainstream media speaking of
you mentioned Vanguard State Street in
BlackRock as three entities essentially
controlling the world if you really look
into it you start to see that they own
each other that there's a lot of the
same people this is from Wall Street Zen
uh State Street is the largest
individual shareholder of or let's get
this right Vanguard is the largest
individual State Street shared holder
with 32 34.26 million shares
representing so Vanguard owns 9.36
percent of State wow amazing and it gets
deeper and deeper the more you look into
it let's pull up some of this weird this
this uh absurdity Oddity Shady dealings
where did he so we have this tweet from
al-walid talal he says I don't believe
that the proposed offer by Elon Musk
54.20 cents comes close to the intrinsic
value of Twitter given its growth
prospects being one of the largest and
long-term shareholders of Twitter
Kingdom khc and I reject this offer
let me Elon Musk responded to this in a
very powerful way but the first thing I
want to do is give you some context in a
story from from Reuters published by
Yahoo finance they say something very
simple let me scroll down so serial
under performer Twitter's lower than
expected user additions in recent months
have raised doubts about its growth
prospects even as it pursues big
projects such as audio chat room chat
rooms and newsletters yes anybody who
knows anything knows that Twitter is
constantly struggled that's right so so
what about Elon musk's premium offer as
a bad deal well for for the prince in
Saudi Arabia maybe it is a bad deal Elon
Musk responded interesting just two
questions if I may how much of Twitter
does the kingdom own directly and
indirectly what are the Kingdom's views
on journalistic freedom of speech
Elon Musk is a brave man in going after
some of the biggest companies and
political uh you know leaders in the
world but he makes a really good point
and I'll throw back to the point I made
earlier I believe the prince uh Olu
Elite is correct 54.20 cents doesn't
come close to the true value of Twitter
which is controlling the American News
cycle especially if you're dependent
upon the United States for weapons and
you like a lot out of the US foreign
interests when it comes to destabilizing
the region no it's true and so people
talk about the fact that Jeff Bezos owns
the Washington Post and it's definitely
very funny there's a lot of great memes
that have come out of that but Elon Musk
owning Twitter would obviously make him
significantly more powerful than any
billionaire who happens to own a single
publication well this is also how Elon
Musk I think makes almost all of his
decisions he thinks what is Jeff Bezos
doing how can I do it better that's his
actual
oh you make phallic rocket ships that's
that's cute Bezos I'll I'll take us to
Mars I think before the show you made it
you framed it in the best way possible
you know so who was it was you Michael
who said or maybe Sheamus Elon Musk is
the first rich person isn't it cool with
their money yeah that's not an original
thought for myself I think it might have
been cerno who said that but then you
said Jeff Bezos how did you frame it
okay uh Jeff Bezos does some I don't
know it does cool things and makes him
uncool no you said he's he's interesting
as a boring person yeah he's like uh
yeah something like that and his rocket
ship looks like a penis
it was really really good one too it's
like it's like oh man so the greatest
joke ever but if only you were there you
would have heard it right interesting in
the way a boring person is basically
yeah in a way a boring person is like he
makes a rocket but it's not cool
a penis did you see Elon and Jeff were
on Twitter talking back and forth about
the home turning Twitter headquarters
into a homeless shelter and uh Basil's
like actually it's a great idea we
converted half of the Amazon I don't
know his headquarters or something to a
homeless shelter and that the employees
can volunteer
the best part about uncool it's like
it's like
the way that this has become a very
hostile takeover kind of situation what
I love about it is every time Elon does
something new and he's rebuffed but
whether it's by the Saudis or whether
it's by the board or aggro wall they say
oh okay they got Elon now uh too bad it
was gonna as if Elon just woke up one
day and said hey bye bye bye bye you
know it's it's hard to buy nine percent
of Twitter you know you kind of have a
plan going into it and you don't become
the richest guy on earth
on accident you know you generally
speaking you're pretty smart about these
things and Elon not forget about Plan B
that he talked about today I bet you
he's got plan C and D and E he's an
engineer that's what they do this is the
contingencies the ultimate thing about
Elon Musk that I've been saying for a
long time he's the greatest living
American he is the only he is the only
person I'm right here okay he's the only
person on Earth right now with a
positive vision for the future of
humanity that actually involves you know
the Dignity of the individual it
actually involves Freedom uh and and
it's and it's constructive he's not a
guy who's lamenting the past he's not a
guy who thinks it's all over he doesn't
believe we're at the end of History he's
a guy who's like let's make things
cooler than anybody's ever made him
let's go further than anybody's ever
gone let's go faster the the greatest
answer maybe in the history of uh well
the greatest answer in the history of
media is when Larry King asked Vice
President Dick Cheney if we should bomb
Iran and Dick Cheney said
for what
but the second best answer in the
history of media is when Jay Leno was
trying to jab it Elon Musk for putting
bulletproof windows on the Cyber truck
he's like why why would you do that and
Elon said
because it's badass
is it you know what you know what I like
about Elon Musk all of those things you
mentioned but he
54.20 everybody's saying he just wanted
to put 420 in that yeah he wanted that
to be in the news I bet he did he posted
he posted the next Twitter board meeting
is going to be lit and it's him smoking
hot he's just he's having fun he's a
choice like Ben Franklin man Ben
Franklin want to make the turkey our
national bird the ultimate troll until
Elon I think people like turkeys I love
turkeys yeah but I'm also I don't know
about trolling I think I will say that
God Kings don't look up to mini folk but
I will say that everything we do with
the daily wire is basically trying to uh
to emulate this kind of an attitude to
say that our best days are ahead of us
we can build Alternatives we can do good
things we don't have to just sit in a
state of Perpetual grief because things
aren't as aren't the way that they used
to be that we can take the great ideas
of the past and build better things atop
them even the same kind of financial
pardon my bluntness stupidity you could
just take your money and run you could
run right now and have a good life and
you stupidly have reinvested your money
and are building all these new companies
what an idiot certain kind of stupidness
putting money into doing good stuff
buying Twitter oh man you know but the
funny thing is there that most rich
people feel that way and that freaks me
out I want to give a shout out to Elon
because
um everything he's doing I I'm inspired
by and I I'm somebody who grew up with
no Heroes I mean they're pro
skateboarders I like that was a great
trick but I never looked at anybody and
said I want to do that and now I'm
watching everything he's doing and he's
like and I'm just like I need 300
billion dollars so I can buy Twitter too
so I can so I can shake things up I once
tweeted at Elon Musk why haven't you
built an Iron Man suit yet and he
responded building Starship and I was
like
is that politically he's got generally
the right ideas because all these guys
look I don't care about cars I really
don't care about electric cars I don't
care about going to space I never
watched star I just watched Star Wars
not Star Trek I just don't shame on you
I know I know everyone knocks I don't
care like none of that interests me
whatsoever but you know what I do care
about uh my Republic and my government
and my politics and all these futurist
guys are always lunatics all these
billionaire Masters of the Universe
always want to enslave all of us and put
us in a prison Colony on Mars and he's
the one dude who's saying no I actually
want you to have your traditional way of
life and your freedom or at a minimum he
said the government will have to pay to
get to the prison colonies
that's the long game always
African-American he's from South America
so do you guys think South Africa so do
you guys think that we should at some
point maybe amend the Constitution so a
non-american citizen can run for
president well at least an
African-American like Elon well the
question is do you really think Elon
Musk would do more good as president as
opposed to what he's doing now no way
yeah not unless he owns Twitter well and
I'll say this I haven't really paid
close attention to him not enough
attention to say I am a huge fan but
stuff like this really makes me like him
what I really appreciate is the fact
that he is countering the overpopulation
narrative we were discussing this before
the show a little bit he says that we're
not going to have another enough enough
people that underpopulation is going to
be a serious problem he's absolutely
correct and how unbelievably refreshing
it is to have an elite who isn't
misanthropic who doesn't say human life
is fundamentally bad or at the very
least needs to be mitigated in some
shout out to elon's Mom dude that woman
is amazing but you know while we're all
uh getting ready to uh uh well I'll keep
it family friendly and just say Pat him
on the back only only to end world
hunger yeah
there are questions about his his
statements on China sure uh so I could
be wrong but wasn't he going on like
Chinese social media and praising the
Chinese Communist party or something to
that effect and that's if that's the
case that's very difficult to be wrong I
don't want to you know call up the dude
who I think is doing rad stuff but you
know part of me is concerned like
maybe the dude's got a big play to make
a bunch of money and he's just it's it's
still flipping the bird to the system
which I can respect but is is the end
goal like you mentioned here's what he
does he tanks the company he buys it he
turns it private changes some rules
lists it makes a quick billion but
that's not a bad thing first of all Elon
Musk doesn't need money he's the richest
person not only in the world but in the
history of the world even when we talk
about the 280 some billion dollars uh of
net worth that he has you have to keep
in mind
SpaceX hasn't had a public offering so
we're not we're not really contemplating
any of the value that exists in the only
access that the United States has to
space uh neural link is probably only
just getting started hasn't gone public
we've never seen in our life not since
Rockefeller have we seen a figure like
Elon Musk the guy very likely could be
the first trillionaire to walk the earth
so we can't even really contemplate the
amount of money that Elon Musk
represents so listen everybody likes to
make a quick billion but Elon Musk isn't
there's there's just no way that he's
motivated in this by that what more what
I'm saying is that the positive aspect
of economic incentive is that it allows
you to do good and do well and so I
think that Elon Musk is doing a good
thing missionally with what he's doing
with faith with Twitter and he will also
likely make a lot of money I don't see
those two things being in uh so the fear
is with the metaverse and with neural
link is someone like Zuckerberg being in
charge and letting him get access to
your brain would you go into the
metaverse Via a neural link if it was
Elon Musk who was the you know God King
of the metaverse no I don't he's saying
he's going to open source the code of
Twitter of the algorithm which is the
first step to trusting the device or the
software you're using if you can
reference the algorithm see if it's
spying on you or not if you have a
device that lets you enter the metaverse
and it's not spying on you that's the
only way to go yeah and so you you
mentioned uh some statements that he
ostensibly made about China this is also
part of why I'm I'm sort of withholding
a little bit I don't know a huge amount
about the guy but part of part of the
reason I was making the point that I
made is because it is really disturbing
that the fact that he is against the
overpopulation narrative it's very
disturbed serving that that sets him
apart from virtually everyone else in
power but I also think that speaks to
what you're discussing which is this
idea of being optimistic and having a
plan for the future I think misanthropy
is the greatest indicator that a person
doesn't have a plan for the future and
there are just a horrifically jaded
pessimist listen the other aspect of
this is that he's probably wrong about
China
and maybe isn't a great dad I I don't
know maybe he's a great dad I don't I'm
only saying Elon Musk is a human being
and all of sin and fall short of the
glory of God and it's not what is common
about us that is noteworthy
definitionally it's what's noteworthy
about us that's noteworthy and so I
think about like George Washington right
and everybody George Washington on
slaves I'm like yeah he was a a planter
in Virginia in the 18th century they all
own slaves that's what's average about
him that's not notable about him at all
in his time and in his place what's
notable about him among other things is
that he free to Slaves none of the rest
of them did so that does that justify
slavery no is that an excuse for slavery
no it's only to say that it's not worth
bringing up that George Washington known
slaves that's not actually an
interesting thing about George
Washington in his time he owned 300
slaves and it was not interesting about
him if I owned even one slave it would
be remarkably noteworthy because in my
time and in my place that would be the
incredibly strange peculiar thing that
reveals something about me and so for a
billionaire uh industrialist to uh
believe in free trade and be dependent
somewhat on uh the mar the China the
Asian markets and probably on Chinese
manufacturing Elon Musk isn't who
outsourced all of America's
manufacturing that happened 50 years ago
60 years ago but he is a manual he is he
is dependent in many ways on that
manufacturing although he's doing
something about it and trying to
manufacture in America but all that to
say
those aren't actually the interesting
things about them they may be negative
things about him but they're not
noteworthy things about him what's
noteworthy about him is that he's the
only guy in that space who to your point
seems to be pro-human he's the only
person in that space who seems to be
pro-speech these are the actual
noteworthy the pro-human thing part is
so important because it is the weirdest
aspect to me especially of Bill Gates
Bill Gates will not shut up about how
there were too many people on the planet
and it's just a lie overpopulation is
completely made up most notably there
was this book the population bomb in
1970-71 it said that within 10 years
even if we now coerce abortions which
the book called for it coerced sterility
even if we do that right now we're
screwed there's going to be 10 in 10
years Mass famine everywhere and it was
completely made up we're 50 years later
the world population doubled
malnutrition is at an all-time low let
me let me pull the story we actually
have the story from USA Today it's from
December Elon Musk says there aren't
enough people Birthright could threaten
human civilization and I think what
people don't realize is that the only
reason we have the level of Technology
we do is due to the Specialties of human
career human jobs so let's go back in
time we're all living in caves human
beings it was possible it was possible
for a human being to have the summation
of human knowledge in their brain it was
possible because we knew so little as
time went on we began to learn more and
more when it came to the point where you
know way back when you could be a jack
of all trades master of all because the
only jobs were Hunter and gatherer the
master of both yeah
Shaman Shaman but you so you were you
were you were let's say you were in your
30s so you are spiritually physically
mentally uh at your Peak and you're like
I am the best human there is because we
didn't know much but eventually got to
the point where we discovered uh mining
um we used animal labor eventually one
person says I've dedicated my whole life
to learning how to tame these beasts and
some other guy said I only learned how
to grow these crops all of a sudden now
the summation of human knowledge splits
and it's only due to the fact there are
more people able to support each other
the more people we have the more
specialty jobs there are I watch this
great Ted Talk a guy made a toaster from
scratch I love referencing this he could
not do it plastic was impossible for him
to make he had to quote unquote mine it
by digging up waste and then melting it
all in all he made the toaster it worked
for about 20 seconds before frying out
and he said it's amazing how this
toaster cost 10 bucks at Walmart but a
single person struggles to make it
there's a there's a book I think it's by
um Lydia help me if you know it's uh no
one knows how to make a pizza
by Julie Julie well I mean no one
outside of Chicago knows how to make a
pizza it's a casserole
the idea is that all of the elements of
a pizza come from so many different
places that's why we have a conquest big
part of it right I started thinking
about this in terms of to simplify the
whole discussion think about a meal like
uh pad thai
the amount on American Pad Thai sugars
fats oils the rice noodles the meats if
you're gonna put squid in it how all of
these things come from all over the
world or maybe even chicken tikka masala
to us like you go to the store and
you're like 15 bucks and they hand you
the bowl but all these ingredients come
from regions all around the planet
especially in Winter where the chickens
might come from the north the tomatoes
come from the south the more people we
have the more unique things we can
create like spaceships yes I think about
this a lot when people try to tell like
hippie dippies in La would always try to
tell you about the natural diet that
they're on you're like yeah what's the
natural diet whatever it was they were
describing you something
describing a way of eating to you that
no human being who lived in nature could
have ever accomplished it's certainly
not in Winter right like what well we
evolved only to eat like Tempest kale
well I I think I think the issue is
um I think overpopulation is an issue
mostly in density and I had this
conversation with Michael malice because
I you know I I think that you got to get
to the Nuance of things often these
arguments don't explore the deeper
issues and I said I think overpopulation
overpopulation is a problem you've got
dead zones in the Gulf you've got
garbage patches you've got the
windshield phenomenon bug uh uh
populations are in Decline and all of
these things seem to be tied to you know
pollution to which Michael Mouse
responded yeah but that's an issue of
density in cities and I'm like I'll
absolutely accept that because I think
that's the root of it and I'm and I'm
willing to say you know what perhaps the
solution is people shouldn't live so
close together in concrete blocks that
smell like sour milk that's right but
it's also
there are so many problems with cities
and in terms of our politics and
evolution and but there's a bigger issue
here the better Point you're making in
my opinion is that as as more and more
humans are born more and more complexity
is added to humanity and that complexity
actually drives things like innovation
so yes you get a spaceship but you also
get uh you also get like super wheat
like Alex Barlow Barlow is the name of
the guy who invented Norman borla Norman
borlock thank you Norman borlach you
know the reason that we have more people
now and we can eat unlike what they
predicted in the 70s is because we
innovated because now there was a need
for something that didn't need to exist
before that so yes the more people you
add to the world
the more complexity is added to the
world the more problems are added to the
world and the more potential Solutions
are added to the world so colonized
space yes yeah and pestilopsis there's a
mushroom that'll break down plastic and
turn it into sugar which you can
actually eat it's called pestilopsis
microspora and if enough people know
about that we can recover like what boy
and slat's doing in the Pacific with the
garbage patch he's actually recovering
it break it down and eat it I Gotta Give
alloy it with it you can turn it into
chemicals and things real real quick
Point um we did an interview with Ben
Shapiro and Ian really shined in his
moment because Ben mentioned in a
lecture that these these uh charts and
predictions about climate change never
consider mitigation factors to which Ian
enlightened ban on carbon capture
graphene production at an adaptive
technology that will eventually what you
can do is you deposit carbon dioxide
onto a Palladium copper alloy uh and
then at at some point we're going to be
withdrawing so much carbon dioxide out
of the atmosphere and producing graphene
in this new building material that we'll
actually be competing with trees and if
we don't do it right and start now and
start organizing we're going to over
compensate and start starving the trees
of carbon dioxide so this view of it is
more of a global cooling perspective
because people don't consider the new
technology that comes out that could
actually threaten the inverse which is
graphene is this Wonder technology that
Ian never shuts up about thank you and
you know I got them a little vile for
for Christmas the year before last but
uh uh production requires carbon capture
and that means we might start mining
carbon dioxide from the atmosphere to
make graphene which is a it's like a
super material yeah it can be you you
it's it can be manipulated in many ways
it's like what superconductor super
capacitor it's a conductor it's like a
touch screen wallpaper you can make it
or you can make clothing that's like a
touch screen computer batteries wires I
mean I'll put it sounds like hell I
don't want to wear that at all it's pure
carbon pure carbon it's organic in in 10
years the conversation on climate change
may be totally inverted to these these
graphene companies are cooling the
planet well we've seen it before because
the The Narrative was initially that the
planet was Cooling and then it was that
the planet was getting hotter and then
it's just that we have climb
didn't they tell people to drive their
cars as much as they could back in the
day like in the 70s you know what
they'll say now too the the libs and the
alarmists will say oh the global cooling
thing that was just a brief media
phenomenon no scientific institutes ever
really pushed that I have half a chapter
of my book just devoted to outlining
every major scientific Institute that
was pushing this stuff they pushed it
for years and now they've completely
memory hold it because it's inconvenient
so of course it's going to happen again
of course they're going to go in the
other conservatives love
post-apocalyptic stories like we love
walking dead and I I say we because I
count myself among the people who loves
things like The Walking Dead but the
truth is my my world view informs me
that it isn't possible not only that the
zombie aspect of the zombie apocalypse
isn't possible but the entire idea of
the complete collapse of human
civilization is impossible
because we are humans and we innovate
because if there really was a zombie
apocalypse I would be the god king of
zombie extermination and I would be
looking up to Elon Musk who would be
killing trillions of zombies somehow
like we we are a highly highly adaptive
species and when a need presents itself
we find ways to meet that need Elon did
make a flamethrower oh I love it he
maybe he knows something we don't about
melting zombies I I discovered that that
same flamethrower is terrific for
melting Harry's and Gillette razors was
that the Elon flame throw it was yeah of
course Jeremy boring was going to use
the boring flamethrower in his video
yeah so I I look you know what my view
on climate change is I have no problem
when you know the The Establishment or
mainstream narrative is that we met
we're we're burning lots of fuels it's
resulting in a lot of carbon it's
warming the planet I say okay all of
that follows as far as I can tell with
logic but I think Ben is right about
mitigation factors and also if you want
to talk more about the heating up of the
planet it looks like there's evidence
that we're still in an ice age and that
what happened 13 000 years ago is a
comet shattered over North America
peppered the glacial continent caused a
global flood but we're still in the Ice
Age we just prematurely melted a bunch
of the ice off so we're going to
continue to melt the rest of the ice and
warm oh that sounds good
I think it's interesting because when
people talk about overpopulation it's
almost as if at the societal level what
we are in the west is that unbelievably
wealthy couple with no children and who
happen to be debating whether or not
they can afford one it's it's just an
unbelievable failure of optimism
ultimately it's funny I was at a a bar
after I graduated college with my father
and he was going around asking young
people are you optimistic and they would
all answer yes and he'd say do you want
to have children oh no I couldn't have
children you know and that stuck with me
because people like to conceive of
themselves as optimistic they like to
say I have an imagination but then
they're not they're not interested in
investing in the future that way and not
only that but they will actually because
it's okay you know if you're not married
if you're not in that position yet but
they will shame other people for having
children and being optimistic and
wanting to bring life into the world and
that's a very ugly thing so my question
is if you know Elon Musk is the one guy
on the other side of this what's the
motivation of people like if if Bill
Gates is wrong if all of these
billionaires are wrong why do they want
less people you know there there was a
great comment that Charlie Kirk made the
other day and everyone made fun of him
for it and it was so smart he said that
tall buildings turn people into Libs and
Media Matters made fun of him and he
said we need to we need to develop
horizontally more than we develop
vertically and everyone made fun of him
except he's completely right going back
to the Tower of Babel into the present
there was a line that Chesterton
observed he said when you're when you're
in the heights of a building of a really
tall building people look like insects
everything seems really really small
when you're down in The Valleys looking
up at great things when you're on your
knees praying looking up only then can
you raise your eyes to Heaven only then
can you raise your eyes to Hope but when
you're at the top of that building you
just feel like God and you're gonna act
like God or what you think God is I
think that's what happened to Gates and
to all these other lunatics who are so
anti-human well and it's funny because
the left will you know the the left has
this hyper fixation on media critique
and I think it's good to critique media
but they'll take the most insignificant
elements of a property and argue that
it's influencing human behaviors in ways
far more profound than I think a
reasonable person would acknowledge but
then when you look at r architecture
which surrounds us at all times they be
they act as if it's ridiculous to even
insinuate more beautiful architecture
creates a more beautiful cultural or
results in better attitudes I I hear
what you're saying Michael but I guess
my question would still be even if they
think they're God why less people I mean
certainly if you were God you'd want no
worse because they actually do see
people as an impediment to Nature and
they see nature as being Supreme so
you'll actually read these people say
things like Elon Musk is going to go to
Mars and he'll just pollute it the way
we polluted the Earth by the people who
who cares
well he's gonna go mine and asteroid the
beautiful natural pristine asteroid that
the asteroid has zero value if there are
no people observing it how dare you say
that people you're saying that people
are Supreme well I'm actually saying the
God is supreme uh and that God made
people and yes people are surprised real
quick just because I want to lose his
point have you guys ever seen or read
Watchmen Watchmen I've seen it but so uh
no no no no I think it was it a movie a
long time ago about 10 years ago but the
graphic novel is considered like the
better form but uh there's there's an
element of the story where Dr Manhattan
who is the one being with Godlike Powers
but he's like I am not a God you know I
can only see my own passive present or
my own past and future he leaves Earth
to go to Mars he's tired of humanity and
he makes this big machine like
clock-like and then there is this uh
young woman he was previously in a
relationship with who wants to talk to
him he brings her to Mars and he says
look at Mars it has existed this way for
eons with not a single human or life
would you say to me that this this
planet would somehow be better with a
shopping mall or parking lots and then
ultimately what it concludes with is he
says to her you continually demand I see
the world your way but you refuse to see
the world my way and so she lets him
using his powers see her entire life you
know basically from start to finish the
way he sees the world but in that moment
he sees her past and in her past
This Woman's mother was almost raped by
a man and then she went back to him
later and conceived this daughter and Dr
Manhattan says seemingly impossible a
woman who had every reason to hate this
man chose to love a man she should have
hated and after all the billions of
years and the energy all coming together
the only thing that exists is you I was
wrong miracles do exist it's you you've
convinced me I'll come back to earth
with you and so thinking about that line
brilliant writing who who was it more
Alan Moore who wrote that man that guy's
amazing but I thought about that and I'm
just like humanity is each individual
human is so insanely unique in the
billions of years it took to create one
person that person will never exist
again no matter how similar or you know
they may be to another person
without people it's a rock that's right
well I I actually beg to differ this is
something called The Blood Falls in
Antarctica and you'll want to pull this
up uh as the glaciers have been melting
and and fresh water is pouring into the
ocean we're like oh it's going to create
dead zones all of a sudden this Blood
Red Water Rivers comes pouring out of
Antarctica no one knows what it is so it
turns out it's iron yeah it's Ferris
what it's doing is it's uh called it's
fertilizing the ocean it's something
called iron fertilization when you
introduce iron iron oxide into the ocean
it grows Plankton which then allows food
for fish and then you see a fish boom so
the earth looks like it's preparing for
us a flood a freshwater flood by
fertilizing ahead of time uh we're not
alone here as humans
no but but we're the only thing of value
here
don't matter without us well but we
can't fish only matter of the fish I
think they of course we matter the most
we exist in nature of course so we have
a uh Sim we're symbiotic in a sense with
nature but nature was given to us by God
that the fish has no concept of the
fishes there's no existential crisis for
a fish uh all anything that we think
about a fish only we think the fish
doesn't think it but well the fear is
that if the ocean were to flood
freshwater we'll lose our fish
population and starve they'll be Giant
and it looks like everybody the Earth is
protecting us yeah yeah but that doesn't
change uh Jeremy or Michael's
perspective I would I would view it sort
of from a more secular perspective you
know you can say we're gifted nature by
God I would look at it like
the uh various forms of life effectively
form a foundation for what humanity is
creating that doesn't mean to say that I
think humans are the Superior in this
context better than any of them of life
just that we're the most adaptable and
smartest and more prone to survival
which from a secular perspective the
strongest survive and everything else
functions as sort of even even from a
secular perspective you'd have to say
we're the only being on the planet that
has a moral code of any kind so in some
sense you could say well we're the most
evil because we violate our moral code
and that's true a lion eating a gazelle
isn't evil it's just a lion so we we
both conceive of the concept of good and
of the concept of evil that's why all of
that lives
do we see animals pray after they kill
prey prey p r a y or p-r-e-y humans
often uh pray before a meal well they'll
pray before a meal but um it also comes
back to after killing that's right
giving thanks to what they have taken
away sort of acknowledging that that
they they take to you know they're
they're receiving something else's life
um I mean maybe there's a case I haven't
heard of of animals recognizing the you
know the the suffering and the pain of
some other animal that they have claimed
their energy to themselves I just look
at it this way
for for the entirety of of life on the
planet
you have this constant battle between
evolution or or you know whatever your
view is if uh a lion is trying to chase
a gazelle and it's too slow it stars the
gazelle get becomes faster so only the
fastest Lions make it and that's you
know natural selection but then humans
come along and all of a sudden have a
new ability adaptation through
intelligence through tool making and now
nothing can compete with us this means
that everything on the planet
we are the ones able to leave the planet
we are we we are in complete control of
the planet we have dominated the planet
in every way and it's not a moral
judgment on the value of life at all
it's just a mathematical equation well
it's a great responsibility too because
if we abuse our stewardship of of the
planet and of all the creatures then
that's I think intrinsically wrong and
that would also be very bad for us so it
entails a lot of responsibility but to
this point here of really humans are
kind of what it's all about on Earth we
don't prosecute the lion when the lion
eats the gazelle it would be absurd to
do that and that's why they're they're
not open to these sort of moral this
translation different question if
someone owned a gazelle and a lion
jumped in and ate the gazelle and then
fled would we go after that lion track
it down and kill it
probably if he were going to come back
and eat another one I I don't think so I
I actually think that if someone had a
ranch in you know the Savannah and they
had gazelle and a lion broken ate the
Zone left they'd be like
I'd go kill that lion I don't I don't
know when you're an angry Wicked Souls
yeah when you look at ranchers for
example in Montana who have a problem
where uh you know wolves you know who've
been reintroduced in the population
start eating their livestock
to defend their livestock they defend
their livestock because of the word live
like right the the more important life
isn't the life of the stock it's the
life of the stockholder but well that
that is so they're defending themselves
when you know we we get mad when
westerners go over and kill lions in
Africa but like the local tribes are
pretty happy about it because they have
to live with those Lions but
so my question is do we do we hunt down
those wolves or we create do we do we
create preventative measures or do we
seek retribution right I'm not trying to
get Vengeance on the wall right I am
trying to solve the problem right yeah
yeah
well the reason I bring this up is
because in the instance where a human
kills a human we haunt that person to
the ends of the Earth that's right to
lock them up or in many circumstances
depending on the severity of the crime
put them to death
I'm not convinced we do that for to the
same degree with animals no I would kill
the last panda bear on Earth
to save the most reprehensible human on
earth even though there are seven
billion other humans that's a great
Point why because the life of any human
is superior to the life of the entire
species of panda now does that mean that
I don't think we have a moral obligation
to be good stewards of the Earth or that
I think we don't have a moral obligation
to look after the panda I'm not
heartless I'm not Matt Walsh I don't
want to I don't I don't mean the panda
harm but I am saying that you know
Dennis Prager has been asking this
question for literally for 30 years now
every year he asks
if your pet dog
were drowning
in the same river current where a total
stranger is drowning which one would you
save and he says 30 years ago everyone
said the stranger and today the majority
of everyone says they're pet dogs
is that good or is it mental illness
it's not good
their wealthy painting or the well
they're foreign or they don't know this
is interesting because I I actually
tweeted something let me see if I can
pull it up so I can pull up the results
yeah because I was thinking about
something similar let me see if Twitter
uh
okay yeah definitely Twitter can pull
this up let me get this Poll for you
guys it's an interesting question in
line with this I am scrolling down and
here we go
would you kill someone to stop them from
stop them from killing your pet 77.4
said yes 22.6 said no I would but I
don't think that these are really
they're not unrelated questions but
they're not the same questions right
killings
killing a human to stop them from
committing uh barbarous act against you
as a proxy your pet is a proxy for you
in that situation is different would I
kill someone who was starving to keep
them from killing and eating my cow no
right would I kill the Intruder who
breaks into my home and as an act of
evil is going to kill my dog yes that's
not he he and he has he has forfeited in
my view he has forfeited his life
because of his act of evil not because
the life of a pet is superior to the
life of a man yep that's not so that's a
a distinct question I agree too and I
think the the instance here with this
question also implies that
you know my view this question is not
that you're you're like I want to kill
this person it's they're they're they're
they're seeking to cause harm to me my
life perhaps your pet is more than maybe
it's your dog you need for your farm the
point is this
it's not that you want to kill the
person no it's that you're put in a
situation where they're attacking you
and it's that people exist in a moral
framework that that animals don't and he
is in violation of the moral framework
this is um I think an incredibly
important question generally about human
beings is at what point is someone
outside of the law right is it that's
what outlaw actually meant historically
that you're no longer subject to the
protection of the law you've forfeited
the protections of law because you've
acted in contravention of them but again
if someone broke into my house and my
house caught fire and I had to make a
distinction a decision of who will I go
in and save the man who was committing a
a bad act or my dog I would have an
obligation probably to save the man but
if the same man were trying to kill my
dog I would have the right to kill the
man yeah well this is just real quick
it's just to say that it's a fascinating
point because I I hope everybody really
thinks down deep about the love they
have for their pet their dog their cat
Turtle whatever and then imagine seeing
a stranger in a current screaming for
help and you being like I ain't saving
that person I want to save my pet I I
think of that question and I'm like wow
you know I'm thinking of my pet you know
I can't bocus everybody loves him and if
I saw bocus frantic in the water and I
saw someone I didn't know I'd go for the
person and then I would be tearing at my
heart that my my pet died yes yeah yeah
but Jeremy is correct when he says it is
not the same question I answered that
yes I would because someone who is
willing to kill a small in my instance
it is a cat who loves me very much like
a dog if someone were willing to kill an
animal then you have to ask what else
are they willing to do which would
inevitably I would think extend to
humans which is something that I think
would be better without the world would
be better without but but again too I
think the the the main issue and the
Nuance of the question is
typically in any circumstance of Defense
you don't want to kill someone exactly
stop them by the way I would also kill
my dog whom I love very much if he were
attacking a child yeah who I didn't know
right right yeah so I want to make this
point that's part of the difficulty with
the framing is just sort of the Nuance
of self-defense self-defense isn't about
saying I want to kill this person or
have a right to kill this person it's
saying I have a right to stop this
person if deadly force is necessary and
they die that's unfortunate but it's an
unintended consequence what if there's
like a thousand people that are dying of
starvation that redirect your water
supply uh because they need to survive
if you go kill them no well they just
die well well do I die yeah yeah what
would you do I get the question is am I
dependent on the water supply as well
yes oh yeah I'm taking my water yeah
well if if it's what's required to
support yourself and your family even if
they don't know who you are and as far
as they're concerned they're just
innocently redirecting water or probably
we're taking it we're taking it to an
extreme and saying were there other
options with their diplomatic options
for resolving yeah clarifying if there's
no malice involved they're just doing
what they need to do to survive like you
said stealing the cow killing your cow
to eat it well but but Ian it's simple
you just go and explain to them then
there's no mouth you say I'm really
sorry but this is the water that I need
to survive and you're you're hurting me
and then if they choose to escalate and
aggress upon you then you've got a
situation what if they just say no
this is actually very interesting in
almost all modern sci-fi if humans go to
Another Place Earth dies the last
spaceship full of humans goes out into
outer space we land on a planet and we
bring some sort of you know disease or
something to the planet and now there's
a battle between us and the and the
native people on the planet
the morality of every modern piece of
fiction says in the end we have to lose
we have to lay down our lives because we
didn't belong here this wasn't our place
but that's actually not the correct
moral answer the correct moral answer is
if I take my family to another planet
and I'm an existential threat to the
people of that planet they are an
existential threat to me I have a right
to defend my life in the life of my
family I I am not asked to subordinate
that impulse that or that that not only
impulse but that right uh simply because
my existence is a threat plus they're
aliens right I mean there's only half
flippantly they're aliens Slaughter the
aliens I don't give a damn they're
foreigners right I mean if we're talking
about you know really then we're talking
about questions of colonialism and it's
the same answer today the the Explorers
The Conquistadors you know they were
terrible awful people Cortez should have
lost and it's an important example
because Cortez is one of the most
incredible great men to ever walk the
earth who took down a demonic Empire
called the Aztec empire that slaughtered
80 000 people women little babies
children in the span of four days by
ripping they're still beating hearts out
of their chest and kicking down a
pyramid so you know the the particulars
matter there and you can actually judge
the the moral question on these the the
particular people in the particular time
and what they're doing why do you think
Jesus didn't Rouse his followers to
fight back
well he does say uh at one point he says
sell your cloak and go purchase a sword
yeah do you think it's just propaganda
that he never really let himself get
caught and killed no that Jesus isn't
Jesus is not a political figure he's
he's almost the only figure in human
history who didn't who isn't political
in the sense that the work that he was
here to do well he's the king I mean
he's the king king of kings at the time
he challenged the political power
structure of the time but he was he was
primarily uh challenging the authority
of man over the soul and the the
authority of death over man he wasn't
the the battle that Christ was here to
fight was a battle against sin and death
well that's a great Point Jeremy because
actually that that is in this ultimate
sense the the political battle because
the the only political power that that
uh anyone has is the fear of death and
Christ conquers it is there anything you
would sacrifice yourself for or your
family for if God called it or whatever
if you truly for Christ right well and
not only for Christ there are uh very
it's very easy to imagine a world where
you are called into con into conflict
called into combat many in our
generation were and they laid down their
lives for their ideals for their family
for their country oh there there is a
noble place for all of that it doesn't
though mean that you have an obligation
not to defend yourself I would go so far
as to say those Aztecs who were horrible
evil demonica I'll grant you all of that
language they also had a right to defend
themselves against Cortez so in an
ultimate moral sense I agree that Cortez
was in the memorial position they should
have just uh laid down their arms but
yes let me uh expand upon up on this
conversation if there was a rapid and
your wife was caught in it
but you know equally distant was a child
who would you save if you don't it's not
my child not your child my wife would
you agree no I would save the child
interesting and you know I'm not
bringing it up because I think there's
an answer I'm just curious it's an
impossible question right uh I I had
this debate with my aunt when I was very
you know a young man I said if if your
husband and one of your children were
drowning which would you say when she
said her husband well I think well I was
somewhat outraged at the time but now I
realize it's just an impossible question
just the point real quick is when Ian
asked what would you sacrifice your you
know your family for you would sacrifice
your family to save the life of a child
or a member of your family I also I
don't know you don't know what would
happen in a situation but I have
mentally attempted to prepare myself to
lay down my life for a stranger like if
I were in a seven and a 7-Eleven and
someone came in and started robbing
people would I put myself between the
gun and an old woman who I don't know or
a young woman whom I don't know I don't
know I don't want to claim virtue that I
don't possess but I've tried mentally to
prepare myself for the fact that it
would be my I believe moral obligation
to lay down my life for a stranger what
concerns me is it so some people and
this is maybe this is an interesting
thing for me to say but some people are
evil and some people are good and some
people are if you if you would sacrifice
your good wife for some evil child that
you don't know
well first of all evil child no no you
can continue
a little demon I think I think a part of
the difference between the answers is
that Knowles's wife told him she's gonna
be watching a show tonight
I would say my wife honey there's a
great sketch in this scenario of a guy
being like I'm sorry honey I have to
save the child and then when he pulls
the cat out he you don't see the kid's
face but then when he when he put the
kid down it's got a Hitler haircut and a
mustache
the reason I ask is because are some
people better than others are some
people more valuable to the species I do
believe that that's true and for
whatever reason maybe the other person's
toxic maybe they've eaten toxic foods
maybe they were raised poorly and like
but if you don't know ahead of time yeah
in a tree in a triage situation right
the the example we keep using is this
like acute emergency there are two
people in the rapid it's in the current
drowning you're not in a position in
that situation to make a moral
determination between the individual and
the other individual you're making
fairly broad don't you think though that
you if you have a as a head of household
as a husband that you you your primary
responsibility in that situation even if
you would lay down your life for the
stranger I I like to think that I would
at least that you have a responsibility
of loyalty and as the head of your
household to go for the wife before the
stranger even if it's little baby Hitler
and arguably too well arguably too with
your wife you can have more children
yeah so that it's it's a tough question
yeah again it's an impossible question
I'm I'm interested in what Michael's
saying that you certainly as a husband
as a head of a house you have an
obligation uh a moral and spiritual
obligation to your wife at the same time
I believe that my wife would want me
would want to sacrifice her life for the
child as well yeah
she's a killer she killed the kid
herself all right all right hear me out
on this right you're standing in front
of a rapid and there's your son being
swept away and equally distant is a dog
but it's got a bag strapped to it that
says cure for cancer on us now well how
do I know some pretentious dog owner
didn't just put that there I would want
to save their kids you know it's so
weird that we're having this
conversation right now because I was
asked this question at Yale about three
days ago a kid a kid walks up and he
says to to end world hunger would you
fellate another man
it's me and it's Senator Cruz is there
too and you're both like answer that
question yeah obviously yeah where do I
sign up and so but I I had an answer
right away I mean you know obviously the
kid was just trying to get some laughs
but it actually is a simple question it
gets down to a basic ethical question
which is do good ends justify immoral
means and then apparently the yales were
confused that I thought that particular
Act was immoral with that you know we'll
get to that later maybe but like why why
yeah but it's but it's
but it's a question and ethics and it's
the the answer is no good ends do not
justify immoral means then you can
justify anything right and probably the
premise in all of these quick cases is
absurd and won't pan out that way so if
it's do I save the human person or the
dog that maybe the dog will magically
lead me to cure cancer you still you
always have to pick the human even if
the dog actually will lead you to cure
cancer yeah it's uh it's interesting I
suppose if you knew nothing if you knew
you're the scientist you've been part of
the team you have the cure for cancer
you put it in the bag so the dog could
guard it somehow both things are now in
the river that in that situation you've
taken ambiguity out right you're not
saving the dog you're saving the cure to
cancer in other words you're allowing
the person you love to die because of a
belief about the lives of thousands or
millions of humans that is a different
that's a different moment
I want to address what you said choosing
to save one or the other are both moral
acts it's it's just a difficult one yeah
and your and your analogy you have a
choice between an immoral Mac immoral
act for a positive end you know what I
mean I I suppose so except
I don't know I mean in the in the act
itself so not mural you're not saying I
the ACT here is I am going to cure
cancer but you know and obviously we're
in a slightly absurd scenario but if
you're saying I'm saving the dog that
does have this real 100 cure for cancer
or you're saving the child I'm not
convinced that those acts are of equal
moral weight I think I don't because I
don't think you're saving the dog that
you're saving uh information
let me clarify what I'm saying is if you
were just to save a dog or save a person
they're both moral acts they're not
equal the human obviously should be
saved but if it was like kill the dog to
cure cancer or save a child it's like
well don't take the immoral act of
killing the animal right but but then
even to take it even further then then
we're really saying okay would you save
your child or a million people who
aren't your child right because that's
what you're saying when you say You're
Gonna cure cancer you're saying a
million strangers or your child and in
that case I think it comes back to the
same hold on although God God chose the
million people what do you mean
God allowed his child to die he did yeah
for the Salvation of many yeah also so
to quote a great man better that one man
should die for the nation yeah yeah
that's true but then no it's actually a
very good point Jeremy but I I still
don't think in that case if I am the
head of my household am I supposed to
sacrifice my son you know God stays uh
Abraham's hand but I don't know that's a
good question that sounds like a test of
God if you found yourself in that
situation I just I have a hard time
believing that you've all forgotten the
economic motivation here to having the
cure for cancer all right all this oh I
would save the dog because I care about
Humanity no you want to sell the Cure no
you're right I see you and then clone
your kid with all the money you make
you're like I've got enough money I cure
you want to you want to take the Cure
and say I'll destroy it if big Pharma as
a Richie Rich let me just tell you that
if I had the kind of money that came
from curing cancer I would probably just
drown kids for sports
nothing nothing it is Ecclesiastes like
nothing can satisfy nothing brings me
joy you know I just Brown children
Jeremy you've been Rich for four days
yeah I don't know man the Marquita said
was right I don't know it seems like
there is a utilitarian aspect to this
because if you're willing to save
information uh or technology and let
people die as a result then it's like
how where does the line draw there hmm
how many people would you let die for
the greatest technology yeah right I
mean so now we're kind of back at the
first part why Knowles is gonna be the
base principle here yeah yeah because if
you 15 if you just reject utilitarianism
and and consequentialism and all that
then you know then it's like then you're
just like you're never confused what's a
good number 42. yeah 42. that's the
meaning of life yeah
yeah wow that's tough man uh the ends
don't justify the means I'll never
accept that because there are no ends
this is what we hear from antifa and
these these uh lying media manipulator
and cult members is that if we just be
evil now it will be good later but it's
like bro it's always now it is always
now I I just I think it's that's
idealistic in that like working out the
ends do justify the pain of the workout
you know the pain of the workout is
intrinsically good because it's it's
strengthening right yeah and and you're
putting yourself through often strain
you're causing yourself harm for a
better end like you're you're
sacrificing for more we're talking about
would you take a drug to make yourself
better well no you're hurting yourself
you're causing yourself problems it is
it is the ultimate Pagan offering is to
is to offer the blood of the innocent
for Prosperity right those Aztecs who
pulled the still beating hearts out of
80 000 women and children were
essentially doing it so that the crops
would grow and when Planned Parenthood
Slaughters 60 million babies in this
country they're doing it so we can make
a little bit more money oh women are
poor oh women aren't going to be able to
provide for themselves if they murder
their own children and spill their
innocent blood they will be and so I I
ultimately think that anytime we ask
these questions at the root we're
actually we're actually asking do we
need to quench The Thirst of Malik or
something yeah yeah let me let me pull
up the story we have uh on that note
from The Daily Mail
Ron DeSantis signs law Banning abortion
after 15 weeks Republican says we are
here to defend those who can't defend
themselves so we also have another bill
here this is from uh oh that's the wrong
store here we go Kentucky lawmakers
override Governor bashir's vetoes on
abortion fairness and women's sports
we're seeing across the country many
states are just saying outright Roe v
Wade is no longer relevant they're just
passing the laws I think Oklahoma made
the that bill which outright makes
abortion a felony well but Colorado
passed a law or Colorado's Governor
passed a law this week or proposed a law
uh that says abortion all the way up
until the moment of birth which also
says that Roe v Wade doesn't matter
right because Roe v Wade disallows that
very same concept so on both sides at
both political extremes Roe v Wade
because Roe v Wade was a nonsensical
ruling in the first place it can't
actually play out consistently so nobody
does you want to break down Roe v
wadeforce i don't think we've actually
ever actually got into the nitty-gritty
well I I don't have my magnifying glass
to find the emanations of the penumbras
that entails this constitutional right
but it's just it's just a nonsense
decision that came out in 1973 that said
because of a vague generalized right to
privacy and the vague emanations and the
penumbras abortions nowhere in the text
and if it is anywhere in the text it's
in the 14th Amendment and it prohibits
abortion but uh because we don't want to
deal with it anymore it created this
fictional right to an abortion and ever
since then the pro-life movement's only
grown stronger you had it come back
again in 1992 with Planned Parenthood
vkc which created a different
justification for abortion because again
as Jeremy said it's not in the text and
so you you come up with this new
justification which focuses more on the
trimesters and viability and that
doesn't make any sense because with new
technology babies are now viable at a
much earlier stage and so right now just
to put on my nullstradamus hat and
predict the future here uh we we do seem
to be at the first spot versus Wade
where the court
I think is likely to overrule Roe and
the reason I think they're likely is
because
from the oral arguments
one you've already got Clarence Thomas
you've already got Alito it seems like
you got Kavanaugh it seems like you got
Barrett it seems like you got Gorsuch
there you go five four you don't even
have John Roberts yet if Roberts joins
the Court's Libs and it's 5'4 Clarence
Thomas writes the decision and man that
decision is going to be good okay so I
think Roberts to preserve the integrity
and legitimacy of the court and actually
to water down as much as he can the way
that they would overrule Roe I think he
has to join the conservatives so then
you get a 6-3 decision this can't be
right Bill Maher said that Republicans
didn't want any black supreme court
justices how could you how could you
tell me it's like the only one we like
is the black guy This concerns me if I
think if they do try to make abortion
illegal that you're going to see a large
uptick in miscarriages and what I mean
by that is women accidentally falling
over on purpose and landing on their
stomachs until the baby's Dead uh it's
terrifying I just don't see that I don't
think you could ever women from killing
of child they don't want you can reduce
the number yeah and I don't think that's
bad people are like you want of women
going into back alleys and putting their
lives at risk yeah but by the way
you can break this down if you want also
overturning Road doesn't make abortion
illegal this is this is the great lie of
the left is oh they're gonna overturn
Roe and no woman will be able to get an
abortion if only but that's not actually
what will happen what happens when they
overturn row is it it basically becomes
a state's rights issue again and as you
can see between the laws in Florida and
the laws in Colorado Federalism is Alive
and Well in this country even 15 weeks
puts you just on average with the most
liberal democracies in Europe no one
allows abortion the way that we allow in
this country no one except the Chinese
and the North Koreans
those three allows abortion the way that
we do in this country so to push it back
to the States is an enormous victory in
fact the Democrats are saying right now
that while they still control the house
and the Senate and the presidency they
should ensconce abortion in federal law
so that even if roe is overturned by the
court in June you still won't be able to
do anything about abortion unfortunately
I don't think they have the votes in the
Senate unfortunately I don't think and
on this point of the back alley
abortions this is one of the biggest
lies from the abortion movement it's
literally a lie it's a lie I mean so one
of the guys who came up with the LIE Dr
Bernard Nathanson one of the founders of
nehrale he he came out and he said 5 000
women a year at least some people say 20
30 000 women a year died from Back Alley
abortions before a roe he admitted they
just made up the number we actually have
the number the government kept the
statistics in 1972 the year before Roe
versus Wade was decided 39 women died
from Back Alley abortions illegal ones
24 women died from legal abortions and
what's even crazier is when you look at
the breakdown of states where abortion
was legal versus illegal your likelihood
of dying in an abortion was basically
the same whether it was legal or illegal
that was in the early 70s it would be
obviously much lower now yeah so we
actually did an educational breakdown of
this on for a freedom Tunes video a
couple years ago but basically in the
1930s you had something like a bit over
2 000 women who had died and been
counted statistically as deaths from
abortions and miscarriages but that
number decreased significantly after the
Advent of the widespread availability of
penicillin it was an issue of women not
getting antibiotics take a look at this
comic I saw this recently I think as I
saw earlier today on Twitter but uh can
we can we pull that up there you go red
states to Blue States the next refugees
women women what they what they fail to
ever bring up in this conversation is
how many women are pro-life I believe
the majority of pro-life people in the
country are female yes well and this is
huge because the left never got the
cultural shift that they wanted after
Roe v Wade so as you mentioned 60
million unborn children have died of
course that's not enough for them they
would rather that number was much higher
and when you look at how long ago the
Supreme Court made its decision on the
question of homosexuality that was what
about 10 years ago and look where our
culture is now I mean we've taken that
almost to its furthest extreme but not
quite yet it's very unpopular to say
anything against gay marriage it seems a
large population a large percentage of
the population believes in it but if you
look at the abortion decision what this
is 50 years ago and still half of the
population is adamantly against it I
bring this up with uh New York there
they recognize 31 different genders but
by law they recognize any possible
gender and gender identity is defined as
effect essentially self-expression so
when the when when the arguments first
come for uh gender identity protections
everybody says we know what this means
and what the intent is there's a famous
story about
um when they outlawed public drinking in
New York that one of the you know City
Council Members or whatever said let
this law never be construed to say a
construction worker can't enjoy a beer
with his lunch sure enough that's
exactly what it means today yeah so in
New York when they say we want to
protect trans people we all say we
totally understand that we don't want
people to be discriminated against and
then what happens is the law is tested
and so someone will say it says
self-expression that's how you defined
it I hereby challenge this and say my
self-expression is that I can wear a
clown costume into work or or a fursuit
or something you know there's an
abortion tie in here too one of the main
drivers of transgenderism in the culture
is that second abortion case Planned
Parenthood V Casey in which the Romantic
poet of the Court Anthony Kennedy said
that at the heart of Liberty is the
ability to Define our own concept of
existence of The Mystery of Life Scalia
mocked it as the sweet Mystery of Life
passage you you do I I don't even have
to say this you don't have the right to
Define your own concept of existence no
one has that right it you you don't have
the ability to do that either you have a
responsibility to accept reality and
live in reality but but if if Kennedy
grants you that well then it's just
self-expression I disagree I disagree
this is my trailer my rules from now on
you will address me as God King well
also
there can be only one okay but but in
all seriousness I mean if you're
extremely wealthy you know Elon Musk or
Jeff Bezos can go to their company and
say from now on you must address me as
this and I suppose if you're powerful
enough you can make people do what you
want them to do Mad King right I mean
yeah yeah that's right it's also bizarre
that like a legal scholar could
determine that the law is about
self-invention isn't it the exact
opposite it's about placing constraints
on people you know I think right I think
you you can Define reality the way you
want but you're subject to the
consequences you can say that there's a
rock right there and I can go hit the
rock but it's Tim it turns out and I'm
gonna suffer mad but I might still
psychotically have to find it improperly
that's still my right as a kid you know
this is my big problem with the whole
conversation about uh about
transhumanity at the moment which is if
if a man says that he's a woman he
legally is a woman
if a man says that he's a carrot and I
eat him they still put me in prison it's
awful
discrimination there's a better a better
example is the man who uh filed a
challenge to his age and said if if
biology is self-identity then I can
identify as younger and they said no you
can't do that and and so I've talked
talked about this before where I you
know I talked to several civil rights
attorneys in New York about the limits
of this and they said the Judiciary
exists to interpret the law if you tried
to say pull a fast one or challenge to
to absurdity they'll throw you out I I
completely reject that that notion that
you could be a biological male six foot
three 200 220 pounds you know muscular
and identify as a woman put on a dress
go to a court and the judge is not
allowed to to Mock You the judge must
accept you under the law but if you put
on a fursuit under the same exact
Provisions in the law you are protected
that the clothing you aware cannot be
discriminated the name you choose so I
am vulciferon Herald of the winter Mists
this is my my identity a judge can laugh
at you then I understand there is a
distinction the argument is that in
modern culture we recognize
transgenderism as a legitimate issue and
we mock furries but I reject the premise
because eventually what we see is people
will test the limits of the law and
eventually in one generation or two a
judge will say it does say that who Am I
who am I to say test the limits of not
only the law but reason itself like I I
think of myself as a magnetic being for
instance not everyone I say that about
you all the time you as well not
everyone has to agree with me on a daily
basis and if I Stray too far from
reality's observation of what I am
they're going to think I'm a psychopath
and put me in like a psych ward so you
have you can self-identify however you
want but you cannot bend reality I don't
know if there's an objective but how do
you do it then in practice is my because
people this is seems to be the middle
ground that people try to find is look I
don't care how you I self self-identify
in your own mind but just don't make me
participate in it but the whole point of
identity is so that you can be
identified so we live in a society we
live in a political Community how on
Earth can you unless you're just doing
it in your basement at night yelling to
nobody how can you have that right to a
delusional identity and not infringe on
my right to reality I mean I I defer
Jesus Christ I believe he was a real man
and he truly believed that God was
slowing through in which it was and
people did not like it and he was like
well I have a choice to make I can
either denounce this and pretend like
I'm not or I can be honest and let
reality do what it will with me and
depending on how truly you believe it
you have to make that decision but but
yeah but the premise there is he Jesus
Is God is God we were told I was told I
do not believe that I don't know him but
yeah
that was a very Trump answer I always
told that I was given that is
one of the best um I just want to
mention I just want to make this point
about uh you know this this sort of
self-invention and coming up with your
own identity my only question is to even
get to that place how much time do you
have to spend just thinking about
yourself no no already really obnoxious
there are many people who you know I
can't remember who told us this story
that someone in their class kept
changing their identity they didn't know
and one week this is who I am then a
week later like no my name's Owen now
and the next week no it's Clyde and it's
just like if if it's if there's no
identity then it can be anything at any
time and there's no legal definition
there's no legal distinction not to just
be not to get too theological here
fellas but isn't it teenagers do that
all the time right teenagers that's sort
of the definition of being 13 years old
as you try on new identities all that to
I'm goth now I'm a rocker or whatever uh
and it's because they're immature and
juvenile and they're coming to some
concept of who they are in at the
burning bush
God tells Moses my name is I am I am
that I am
that's a name he's saying I am being
itself
and your identity must be in me for you
to make any sense I am the Divine logic
of the Universe I am being when you find
your identity in I am
things make sense when you ignore that
and turn away from I am at all times
throughout every society in all of human
history things start to go pretty kooky
and you're left with a pathetic question
which is who am I changes by the day I
want to go back to abortion real quick
because I'm thinking about this here I
am you know surrounded by more religious
individuals who are much more staunchly
pro-life and I've always so be careful
right well I've always said I was
pro-choice and I think one of the issues
is that when you actually break down the
the absolute Nuance of the argument well
then it's like what does pro-choice and
pro-life really mean and I think the
pro-choice people typically do not
understand or there's not enough
complexity in the argument so for
instance we were talking with Matt Walsh
he argued that abortion is the
intentional Act of Killing a child and
I'm like right I think that's wrong
but I think there are circumstances
where a medical procedure would be done
that would remove a baby from a mother
and that's where the Nuance comes in so
ultimately the conclusion was if you
have to do something for the sake of the
mother that would result in the the the
child being removed you just don't try
to kill the child and I said interesting
I don't think the pro-choice left
understands the rights position on that
I think they you know first of all
there's a real problem with the left's
argument on pro-choice in that it is a
scientific fact that life begins at
conception and any argument otherwise is
illogical it makes literally no sense
right if you want to get to an
authoritarian libertarian argument on
medical choices for private individuals
that's where I'm kind of at but then the
argument never actually addresses the
true stance that that you guys might
have or that um that Matt Walsh brought
up in that oh yeah absolutely do the
procedure to save the mother's life and
try and save the baby too and I'm like
well yeah of course oh you're saying
they shouldn't just kill the baby
afterwards well I agree with that
I don't think most pro-choice people
understand that's what you're saying I
don't think they understand much of
anything about pro-life and I'm not
saying that to be a jerk I was
pro-abortion for 10 years in my teenage
years I wrote that this was during his
goth phase it was during my gosh no I
pro-choice Pro Aztec I guess I would
have said pro-choice but I mean I grew
up in New York surrounded by liberals I
went to a very liberal college and I
just didn't I just thought conservatives
wanted to control women's bodies I
actually that's all I knew and so I
thought I can't I'll cut taxes but I
don't wanna probably be cool man I know
man I was smoking doobies and stuff I
was like Elon Musk uh but were you like
well hold on some like Elon Musk and
then I had a conversation with it with a
woman bioethicist and I made all these
stupid utilitarian arguments as to well
you know all the Freakonomics arguments
well abortion it stops overpopulation
and uh it lowers all these sorts of
Social pathologies and she said oh okay
Michael so which one of your Arguments
for you know lowering crime and well
welfare dependency which one of your
arguments is is not an argument for
killing young black men in inner cities
you're just making all it's the same
argument right and I thought oh yikes I
don't like that and and I thought about
it more deeply and I thought I realized
oh they're not just evil people trying
to control women's bodies maybe they
maybe there's actually to this something
to this idea that a baby is a baby and
we shouldn't kill it you know I said
it's a scientific fact that life begins
a conception and uh I just have never
understood any logic and any
circumstance even when I wasn't
listening to more pro-life nuanced
arguments that you know I think I think
was it vashu said when when he was asked
by Charlie Kirk when does life begins I
don't know sometime after birth I think
that's what he said then I'm like well
that can't make sense I think of it as
life beginning and conception but at
what point is it a human ah well it's
not a giraffe it is a human life the
real question is when is it in sold and
the answer is we don't know it is it is
possible that we it is possible that we
could discover uh that life does not
begin a conception you know I know a lot
of people not I'm sorry not that life
does not begin a conception which of
course it does not that human life
doesn't begin a conception which of
course that it does uh of course it does
but that
the installment of a of a of a child
does not begin a conception the Bible is
not clear about this there's an argument
for you know wrestling in the womb and
we like some pro-life likes to use that
but there's also the breath of life I
mean there are real questions about
to the extent that it is unknown though
what are we left with we're left with
the things that we do know that life
begins at conception that the life
conceived is a human life that's what we
can measure that's what we can know
that's where we have to actually make
our decision and to the extent that
those things are knowable and that we do
know them in my view therefore we're
left with no other conclusion but to
protect that life you know that's a good
point Jeremy and it raises the question
of all right so how certain are you how
what are you willing to risk you're
three percent sure that you're going to
kill 60 million babies right but there's
also sometimes you'll hear the pro
choice pro-abortion people say well in
the Christian tradition they actually
had carve outs for some abortions and
they always cite Saint Thomas Aquinas it
was very very important doctor of the
church and Thomas Aquinas it seems at
least at first glance to be a little
unclear on this question between what he
considers to be you know the first step
of the baby being made there's some
period of time before the baby is unsold
but it's a it's based on really
ignorance of Thomas Aquinas because
Aquinas is using Aristotle's physics
he's using Aristotle's understanding of
biology not his fault not Aristotle's
fault they didn't have modern sonograms
and so what they believed was that the
sperm acted on the blood and produced a
vegetative soul but there wasn't really
anything even resembling life until the
quickening and you had this distinct
human being and we just we just know now
that isn't true we know that the sperm
and the egg come together they cease to
be what they were and they become a
unique human life and they're growing
and so it's it's no knock on Aquinas or
Aristotle but by their own logic Life
Starts pretty much just right Atkins and
also I will I if I'm not mistaken the
official position of the Catholic church
is that the the the
um person is in Soul that fertilization
the heartbeat personally because that's
when the magnetic field begins to become
produced it's it's I think Jeremy hit
the nail on the head you know we're left
with what we know life begins a
conception and every argument I've ever
heard and I welcome any you know more
pro-abortion Pro left whatever
pro-choice whatever they want to say to
have this discussion because you know I
do feel it's like here's here's a
pro-choice you know Onslaught
essentially I'm pro-life Onslaught
um scientifically just what is life a
unique set of DNA and I've heard all the
arguments and ultimately you know you
say
um you know you know mentioned you know
when does it I can't remember when can
you discern that it's a human well so
you know the argument's been made a
million times if a person is brain dead
is it still a person is it alive well of
course it is and so there's the question
of how many grains of sand make a heap
sure but there's still sand there the
process of creating the Heap started
when you began trickling sand you know
onto the ground if we want to say at
what point does become a person sure at
what point is it a human life since the
beginning when the process begins to
create the human life I like the unsold
question
um if you look up the human magnetic
field Taurus you see this that the
heartbeat itself is producing in a
magnetic field around the human body I
think that that magnetic fields
interaction with the Earth's magnetic
field and maybe the solar magnetic field
and even the galactic is producing this
God Consciousness but but isn't the soul
metaphysical meaning so magnetic forces
are acting on the physical world but
isn't the soul in order for it to be the
soul and not to be the body doesn't it
have to not be physical it has to be I
say of the soul that it's the uh the the
intersection of the Transcendent and the
material so to the extent that you're
describing the material perhaps uh
expression of the soul that might very
well be true I'd be curious if the
proto-hartbeat produces a magnetic field
which to our current question would be a
really important one because you know
the cells begin pulsating as a heartbeat
before the heart is actually formed in
utero which is part of the part of the
whole kind of conflict about heartbeat
laws right is what is actually the
heartbeat but I I think your magnetic
field being is actually really
fascinating and we should look and see
if there's if the protocol heartbeat
produces the field as well okay there's
no I I really don't feel like pro-choice
exists anymore and I think it's it's
become a shield for what is overtly
pro-abortion yeah the reason is I grew
up
um with a family that said abortion was
wrong
but there are circumstances where it's
not the position of the government to
intervene in a private medical practice
and it becomes scary in certain
circumstances but uh we were a
pro-choice family we voted Democrat
every step of the way yeah and the
conversation was always it's a terrible
thing that exists but
and and nowadays that's not even the
argument the the the argument is women
who cares Lena Dunham said she wished
she had one safe legal and rare remember
all that back in the Al Gore days not
that long ago not that long ago and this
is this is what's been happening now
it's shout your abortion right yeah
exactly and and you get an abortion and
you get one and Lena Dunham said she
wished she had one and she was like you
know I do all this advocacy and I just
feel bad because I didn't and I'm just
like did you see this tweet the other
day this woman tweets out a cake yes and
it was the cake said it's a boy and then
she crossed out the why and wrote ershin
and it seems like this was legit and she
said look I I just had my abortion and
abort abortion is a really traumatic
thing to have and it's why you got to
surround yourself with love and
friendship all the time and celebrate it
and the question of course it naturally
follows is
why is it traumatic yeah yeah if it's if
it's something to be celebrated what's
so traumatic about it well kind of like
working out is traumatic to the muscles
literally like you're inducing trauma so
it can regrow stronger
well I don't think this is the baby
regrows stronger right I mean what if
she's speaking about it she's speaking
about it emotionally right that it
creates a trauma is is the idea that the
abortion is an edifying thing and
therefore we should have a lot of them
to get much stronger that's right this
is a great conversation it's
philosophical it's religious it's legal
I want to focus back on the legal though
just for a minute because a lot of
people listening now know that the court
is going to make a decision in June and
they may not know exactly where they are
on some of these philosophical questions
uh they may be you know persuaded by the
Catholic view they may be persuaded by
the pro-choice view uh or or um the
magnetic view the magnetic field oh yeah
I can go deep on that but but the legal
question is what's before us and what
the left likes to do in these moments is
to get people to hyperventilate with all
these hyperbolic kind of statements
about what's going to occur so just I
think the key things I would want people
to leave with are
overturning Roe v Wade does not make
abortion illegal
overturning Roe v Wade gives the states
the right to make abortion illegal and I
doubt that very many states would do it
yeah I doubt that very many I doubt that
very many even conservative States would
go all the way to saying that abortion
must be illegal in all cases I think
that the most likely thing is that
you'll see a radicalization on the in in
blue states where we where we basically
get rid of all the constraints of Roe v
Wade and Casey on viability and other
sorts of standards and you can
essentially kill babies after birth
which is actually a thing that happens I
think on the other hand you'll have a
few states that Outlaw abortion I think
you'll have many states that take up
more of a European Standard which would
at least reduce the most horrific
instances of abortion where babies who
can actually feel are being dismembered
so that they can be extracted from their
mothers and and in that world the
cartoon Tim that you put up with the
refugees
well I think that's
uh sn9 statement that all women are
gonna there actually will be more voting
with your feet there will be a further
kind of balkanization politically of the
country I happen to think that that's a
good thing
I'm I'm really interesting what I'm
really annoyed by in all of this is that
we've come to the point where in
Virginia and in Colorado it's it's like
a a full-term baby can be aborted and
it's just like that you know this is why
I say life begins a conception as a fact
right yeah you you can't abort a baby at
eight months because it could be taken
out and just placed on a table and it
will live you're literally just
executing it and they call it an
abortion we you know as soon as the
conception occurs there's a unique set
of DNA and that's all you really need I
I accept that if we look at a single
cell on Mars and say it's life we can
look at a single cell in woman and say
we have life it's it's it's it's the
argument pro-life people often bring up
that the scientific Community says they
found single cells here is it life but
they won't say the same thing of a human
being I I accept the scientific reality
of a unique set of DNA the problem is
as I mentioned with my family growing up
the left stance now is if you are
pro-choice you are on board with
unfettered access at any point to some
of the most disgusting procedures of
killing rabies and I'm not talking about
the the the right wing perspective of
you know on day two of you know a
fertilized egg you're killing a baby I'm
saying imagine
that you are a a Democrat and the baby
is or uh guys know he would deliver the
babies kill them there's a guy right now
cesare santangelo the story just broke
he's done this to hunt at least hundreds
of babies probably thousands of babies
we're talking full term or nearly full
term in some cases almost certainly were
actually born first and then he's
killing them he's the worst serial
killer in America and no one wants to
say his name just like us know because
the process of abortion for the process
of late-term abortions is they just kill
the baby which could survive on its own
that's right and and the other thing is
and Michael alluded to this technology
is part of this conversation yeah
because the the age of viability gets
younger and younger and younger as we
get better and better and better at
medicine at medical procedures it's very
conceivable that one day you'll be able
to extract a zygote out from a woman and
put it in some sort of pod and raise it
uh up until you know it's able to
breathe on its own as a and get a
driver's license uh the so the question
is like even if viability is your
standard what does viability mean and
they'll say well viability means when it
can survive on its own two-year-olds
can't survive on their own right well
let's go to super connection can I just
make a point because I want to ask you
guys how we're using these terms I want
to make sure I didn't make an accurate
statement earlier but when we use
conception versus fertilization are we
using these interchangeably how are we
different I'm using them interchangeable
okay yeah it's a into the Aquinas point
because Aquinas would have said that
abortion begins a conception the
question is how long does conception
take so it's actually an exception or
I'm sorry life begins to consideration
but so it's that is an important
distinction we just know now because of
medical advancements in technology we
know that fertilization and conception
and the sperm and the Egg going away in
the new life beginning that they are the
same act okay yeah it's it's a new life
it's it's an independent DNA set that
begins replicating and yeah and it may
never even implant like it's entire the
entire life of that new distinct DNA
life form yeah and it may be a matter of
hours but for those hours it was a
distinct life a human and we believe
that a human has value that's the
definition is it human life I still I
have not I'm not comfortable saying yes
at this when when people say uh you know
I hate the the the
sophistry on this one when they say oh
well sometimes it you know it won't
stick and it'll be washed away or it'll
be removed from the body or whatever and
I'm like yeah no one killed that like
killed the life on purpose that's right
sometimes people have heart attacks and
die we don't seek out you know nature
and be like ah we're gonna well let's go
to super chats and read what the
audience has to say in the questions you
guys have smash that like button if you
have not already subscribed to this
channel share the show far and wide if
you do like it and um let's read what
you all are talking about oh yeah go to
timcast.com be a member we have that
member segment coming up in just uh
about an uh 11 p.m or so
all right oh here's a good one saki's
red Landing Strip says Knowles eh was
Clavin busy yeah real nice Buster real
nice you can make it up to me by buying
speechless controlling words controlling
mines and paperback yeah yeah Cleveland
was busy busy not being invited on the
show tonight
it's a good one we love you Clavin find
my Geisha says I know that Michael
believes in regulations on the Second
Amendment and Tim does not I'm in Tim's
camp but would like to hear a debate on
the difference I think I'm learning
something new about my political
philosophy okay so why do you want to
say maybe yeah I don't know maybe
Cleveland should have come on tonight
yeah no I don't I can't think of a I
mean other than I mean I I don't think
that individuals should be allowed to
possess nuclear weapons but that's
pretty much the only limit I've got hold
on do you think people have the right to
bear nuclear arms I I would restrict
that right but but do you think they
have the right
no I don't think so but the Constitution
says the right to keep and bear arms
shall not be infringed it does yeah but
you know one aspect of my see view of
the word yeah got me no one of you of my
my politics is I'm not merely looking at
the text on the page whether to
interpret it in the wacky kooky modern
leftist way or even in the supposed
originalist way because there were
different versions of originalism
there's original intent there's original
public meaning which is what Scalia was
a big proponent of I take into account
the American tradition I think that the
tradition matters I think the way these
laws have been understood over time
matter and so I I've never seen the
right to uh to make keeping a nuclear
arm privately recognized so I'm well
that's because they stole it uh corsairs
and privateers were commonplace yeah uh
uh private Mano war with grape shot
could level a coastal town it was owned
by a guy the East India Trading Company
the founding fathers uh uh we believed
we were allowed to have cannons they had
yeah multi-barrel so at what point did
we say the government has the right to
keep and bear arms that we do not well
certainly by the point of the
development of nuclear weapons I mean
I'm not disagreeing with you that you
can you could have privateers and I'm
all for sea shanties so sign me up I'm
all for people having cannons or
whatever they want but so yeah I I think
that the real distinction is I'm not
saying people should have nuclear
weapons and I think I agree with you I
think uh as I stated on the on the
episode when we talked about this where
the left took it out of context to try
and claim I believe to try and claim I
said they should have nukes I said I
think we could all come together on this
one and actually amend the Constitution
say yeah except nukes and biological
weapons I think most people would be
like yeah we're cool with that but it is
worth pointing out when we talk about
the Constitution there's two separate
things we're talking about there's
Capital C Constitution which is that
piece of paper and then there's the
lowercase C Constitution which is how
the government actually works and so I
love the sheet of paper I'm all for the
Constitution I'll defend my
constitutional rights tooth and nail but
we also have to accept that the way our
government works is not merely dictated
by a piece of paper but the way we live
it and we've lived it for centuries and
and if we deny that reality we're not
going to get very far in politics I
think my point was that right now
individuals under the Constitution do
have a right to keep and bear any arm
period that we that the constitution
protects that right if if we don't like
that and I think most people wouldn't it
has to be amended you can't just one day
wake up and say we've all agreed I mean
it
we practically don't have that right now
you're right that the text doesn't say
that and we haven't had to change it so
yeah I'm inclined to agree with you Tim
uh that I think that the best use of the
cons the well Michael what you're saying
is true I wish that it were not I think
that I think that we are supposed to be
governed by the Constitution with a
Capital C and that if there are things
about the capital c Constitution we
don't like we're supposed to amend the
Constitution and that the real problem
is that we've moved away from the entire
concept of enumerated rights so even the
fact that we're talking about the Second
Amendment as though that's the guarantor
of our right to bear arms even that
right is a misrepresentation of the
founding intent which was that Congress
didn't have any right enumerated to them
to deal with this issue in the first you
know Scalia he said he interpreted the
Second Amendment to mean that you could
have any commonly held arms and where
did he get this from well I don't know
he said he was a soft originalist that
he wasn't his Hardline originalist and
the the fact is I got to meet the guy
when I was a student and we were all
asking him about the Bill of Rights and
he said who cares about the Bill of
Rights what protects your rights is not
the Bill of Rights what protects it are
the institution that the the real guts
of the Constitution set up which have
been changed and I think decayed over
time and so when I'm when I'm talking
about the lowercase C Constitution I
just mean as a practical matter the way
that we're actually going to maintain
our rights and our liberties and our
Traditions is
is by the way that we live by the way
that we're actually governed the very
fact that administrative agencies make
all of our actual laws now is something
that we have to Grapple with that's the
way our constitutional works it's not
just to build up on Capitol Hill you
know all right let's read some more we
got Christina H who says can the daily
wire make the novel one second after
into a movie it's about a small town
trying to survive if the US is hit with
an EMP attack excellent shows this week
y'all thank thank you looking forward to
miss Cooper tomorrow well there you go
they want one second after have you guys
heard of that I've not heard of one
second after but we're making lots of
movies and TV shows and kids content and
as we as Michael has shamelessly
promoted his book I will shamelessly
promote the work of the daily wire and
say that uh we're busy building
Alternatives cultural Alternatives
because uh not only are we not
ultimately governed by the capital c
Constitution where's the pity we're not
really even governed by the lower KC
Constitution uh we're governed more than
anything by the lower KC culture and
yeah more than that even the technology
that we have that allows us to formulate
the culture like if someone can shut you
out of Technology shut you out of the
the Town Square you're you're not able
to influence the culture well speaking
of Shameless promotions Freedom Tunes is
still not to 800 000 subscribers and we
released one of the best videos we've
ever released shout out Jeremy's razors
[Laughter]
I'm just saying that it's strange that
I've never seen Sheamus and Ben Shapiro
in the same room use that information as
you will well you might send it
relatively soon okay here's the thing so
if you're gonna accuse me of actually
being meant appear that's actually
ridiculously offensive okay Ben Shapiro
is not nearly as intelligent or handsome
as I am all right and he knows it he
knows it fighting words all right oh man
you see they're starting it again and
it's Michael's fault I was listening to
a review of the show and I heard Ben and
I thought it was you
it's very high bar okay gang they're
starting it again I blame Michael for
this Eric Miller says Tim you've heard
of hanlon's Razor but have you heard of
Jeremy's razor that which you can pay
tribute to wopeness you can pay Tribute
to Freedom you can use that if you want
Jeremy that's pretty good wow fantastic
how's the razor company going along yeah
and and you've heard of Occam's Racer
the Razer company is doing great since I
was last with you guys we've sold 30 000
more razors and uh people I think I
think people are amused uh by the fact
that we uh that we're having a good time
actually building these Alternatives and
challenging uh the sort of leftist
homogeneous in our economy and in our
culture uh and I think it's only the
beginning what I'll say is I'm gonna get
incredibly wealthy by uh by taking
advantage of all the opportunities that
the left gives us and they give these
opportunities to us by active hubris
that they believe that they can take
conservatives for granted and still cash
their checks because conservatives have
no no Alternatives but I'm not the only
one who's going to get wealthy there are
a lot of guys out there Dan bongino is I
think a great one and there are more I'm
sure on the horizon who we don't even
know yet who see all these opportunities
being created and are going to seize
them and I genuinely believe over the
next decade we're going to create
economic incentive for the left to
actually not be able to take us for
granted can I tell you something too I I
shave with a Jeremy's razor right now I
previously shaved with a Gillette
because I ditched Harry's before
Gillette I shaved with a Harry's and
Gillette was bad too because they were
half trans now also yeah but the
Jeremy's razor is a good razor it is a
better razor than the Gillette and the
Harry's razor I thought it was the best
a man you can get yeah probably not all
right Murph tries says Tim when will
chicken City be uh by the airport TV
contracts chicken City 24 7. uh I am I
am proud to announce today chicken City
netted 1 500 well done we reached 650
Peak concurrent viewers on the channel
today and it's a 24 7 stream so it's
quite a bit for a new show we're at uh
29 000 subscribers and we've
consistently raised made over one
thousand dollars on chicken City every
day
I am very proud chicken City Chicken
city is truly greater than CNN plus
well the funny thing is solvent CNN with
10 000 daily active users and with their
50 off price of three dollars a month
chicken city is on track to gross more
than CNN per month than I've CNN plus
per month so um it's more informative
content too well the first the first
thing I posted when it went live was a
person who watches nothing but chicken
city is better informed than a person
who watches CNN that's true you know the
quote from Thomas Jefferson
all right where are we at let's grab we
got we got we got too many super chats
man way too many
all right there's a lot of people saying
shout out this is cool cool yes all my
favorite uh all my favorite Willie Baron
says all my favorite people Tim Cass and
daily wire heart attack thank you very
much keep breathing all right Evan says
great to see Evan boy boy Mel great to
see Knowles and the god king Elon is
right there is potential in Twitter but
it's essentially a rage chamber
transparency would be much uh a much
needed shot
favor
shout out my parody fighting game
what does it say celebia brawl fight
caricatures of celebs on mobile and have
a blast uh love the show and love the
con that does sound like a blast I'm in
yeah sign me up yeah right on we have
the screen zoomed smaller so we could
fit more on and it's getting harder to
read but uh here we go a free thinking
dog says chicken marsala is Italian
British food sucks
yes all right thank you for the thanks
for your two bucks
all right
let's grab some more Joe Byrne says you
can also create graphite by crushing
coal into powder and microwaving it
supposedly we could still use coal mines
I think you mean graphene though well
you can actually upscale coal into
graphene they're working on doing that
with lasers so it's not going to
supplant the coal industry like I
thought before hopefully we'll figure
out how not to supplant the copper
industry because that's basically the
last roadblock before Inception Ian how
do you learn this yeah I listen a lot I
have a good memory I read a lot of
science journals and talk to scientists
I have a lot of friends that are
scientists like Jeremy riss the alien
scientist highly recommend his channel
very wise man so if you are do you like
own any stock or business investors I
thought about I went down to South
America to start a graphene company in
uh in uh Santiago Chile we had an
investor but it didn't feel right doing
it in South America I want to do it here
if we're going to do it uh when when Ian
started ranting about this I found a
company that produces graphene and I
bought like 60 shares nothing crazy but
I was like there's this stuff called
turbostratic graphene where you can hit
it with lasers and create these like
these Wafers of it and then if you can
somehow uh what's called you bend them
1.1 degrees and you can start to get
this incredibly super conductive you
start to layer it at like 1.1 degrees uh
1.56 degrees I think it's starting to
make like a 64 tetrahedron like a
two-dimensional tetrahedron shape and
we'll be able to like conduct lightning
through it and stuff
wow yeah if we can somehow use lasers to
flash it into position we'll just be
able to create this
mad awesome this is interesting Brian
Webb in reference to Watchman says Alan
Moore regretted writing the comics
because he claims that he broke the
genre
maybe
um you know I look at a lot of his work
and it really added a lot of depth and
philosophy and ethics and morals to to
comic books he was he was amazing
Watchmen was brilliant the bad uh the
bad guy wins basically excellent
excellent writing I love the movie too
all right Nevermore says Michael on your
comment about tall buildings make people
liberals I live outside of Portland
Oregon and the tall buildings have
always felt unnatural dystopian and
depressing to me yeah this is an
important point there was an obit in the
New York Times the other day and it's
the that's the only good part of the New
York Times it was about this guy
Christopher Alexander who is an
anti-modernist architecture guy
especially in the 70s he hit his stride
and he made a really simple point but
it's it's important especially for
conservatives to get but really for all
of us any place you are is going to
elevate your spirits maybe just a little
bit or lower your spirits any place that
matters because we're in the physical
world conservatives used to get this so
much Edmund Burke who's kind of
considered the father of modern
conservatism he was an aesthetic
philosopher it actually like Beauty and
place and that actually matters to us
and so if you live in some dystopian
glass and steel hell hole you're not
going to feel great have you guys been
to a castle uh medieval castle I was in
uh in Scotland and Edinburgh and I think
it was Mary Queen of Scots I had a
chance to go into her bed chamber where
she would get dressed and there's a slit
window you'd look out and you look down
at the people walking around it's
humbling because I was putting myself in
her mind thinking like uh my subjects
and like just what kind of ego that
builds to see these tiny humans but
imagine being all the way all the way up
at the top of a skyscraper well it's
like the just putting ketchup on your
steak and eating your taco salads the
best in the world yeah there's a Family
Guy joke where all the rich people are
hanging out with Peter and they're like
in a plane or something and then he's
like wow look at the people down there
they look like events and Bill Gates
goes they are ants
all right NY bsfp says I'm confused why
Jeremy would hunt down the last Panda to
save the life of the most reprehensible
human but two minutes later says he'd
kill a person to save his dog because
some people are bad huh
because uh it's two separate questions
would I kill someone who was in the act
of committing evil to preserve the thing
that I ascribe value to perhaps
that's a separate distinct question from
is Panda life or dog life intrinsically
more valuable than human life so it's
just using it's using examples to try to
articulate two separate points you're
killing a burglar I in the dog example
that's right you're killing a burglar
I'm gonna take credit for this idea here
uh Preston Witherspoon thank you for
writing it but um I'm just gonna take
credit he says Tim please let Jeremy
know if daily wire creates a platform
like Netflix that streams regular movies
and TV shows millions of us would leave
Netflix and stop giving them money who
needs Netflix originals anyway did you
guys uh realize that I think it's a
great idea for your platform to try and
make a streaming service with original
content which is exactly I was thinking
about it that is what we're doing thank
you I think that it's humble your
statement is humbling a because we we
have we've released uh four feature
films and we're releasing two
documentaries next month we have two
Series in development right now and five
kids series it's humbling because a
despite our best efforts to Market this
idea I think there are a lot of people
who don't know about it and B even to
the extent that you do know about it and
perhaps you do what you're saying is we
we haven't reached a point of viability
yet where this is worth your money and I
understand that we we certainly don't
have enough content to make an offering
to you on on a straight value
proposition level anything like Netflix
I mean essentially for 10 bucks you can
come to the Daily wire and watch four
movies or for that same 10 bucks you can
go to Netflix and watch every movie and
television show ever made we're aware of
that distinction but
what we're basically saying is that the
mission is part of the value that we're
giving to our subscribers as well and
that the more people subscribe the
faster we'll get to that ultimate value
proposition where we have enough content
where it is well and truly uh worth your
money I think it's worth it now because
you also in addition to that content I
mentioned you still get the Ben Shapiro
show the Candace Owens Show the Andrew
klavan show the Matt wall show we throw
Michael on there just for charity for
charity so you do get a lot of value
from the platform but but I certainly
recognize that we got a lot of work to
do interesting if you start buying
content that's going off contract at
Netflix and Hulu because on your
platform they're going to get a lot more
attention being first in it's true the
order I like that show it was like a
teeny bopper CW style werewolf thing and
I was watching and then I was like
they're not making another one man I was
I was I was I was enjoying it it was you
know the TV was on but anyway uh let me
just say I have an LG TV
there's no there's no Ott app for some
of these smart TVs for daily wire and I
wasn't able to watch it and then on our
Sony TV I wasn't I don't know if I'm
just doing something wrong or if you
guys are you know moving are you gonna
get the Ott's yeah we're building Otts
actively right now the the couple that
we have Roku and Apple tv are getting
improved because they uh they're they're
not at the level that we think they
should be uh but yes that's a place
we're making very active events and just
because of the jargon it means over the
top so it's a reference to uh TV smart
TVs Roku Apple TV so that on your TV you
can just have the app so you can't you
can currently on Roku and Apple TV uh
that's a product that will improve
Samsung Vizio those are all I think in
development right now I think you're a
victim of your own success in that
everyone is so eager and excited for the
prospect of real content and and good
content that they expect you to have it
instantly yeah you know and I you know I
think a year you guys are going to be
the snowball rolling down the hill great
speed
so I'm excited thank you for sure all
right what is this
Prometheus says make wearing swords
fashionable again and have you heard of
borophene daily wire anime when God King
would you like to answer first not soon
enough I think morphine I've heard this
is like the ninth time someone's told me
about it in the last two weeks so uh
it's Boron it's similar to graphene I
think it's similar to structure
structurally but it apparently is
incredible
orange red says Tim in the movie The
Good Son an ant has to choose who to
save her nephew or her son watch it
Macaulay Culkin and Elijah Wood play the
kids I think I saw that when I was real
young it isn't like one is is a bad kid
and one's a good kid or something like
just a genuinely evil child yeah and
there's a whole debate between uh
whether it's psychopathy and mental
illness or just true evil like you've
got to boil it down no two kids that are
in a river going down full speed and
one's just a really nice good kid who
wants to help everybody but the evil kid
is holding the cure for cancer yeah I
would kill Macaulay Culkin I think and
of course the evil kid of course the
evil kid has the cure for cancer right
how do you come across that he stole it
from a lab exactly is that evil kid is
Big Pharma I'm not gonna give it to us
anyway don't save all right hold on hold
on hold on let me fix the scenario the
evil kid and the good kid are both in
the river the evil the evil kid has the
cure for cancer and you have a very
powerful net gun that just so happens to
fire two Nets at the same time Tethered
to a rope that will save them
two good kids no we saved them we saved
them of course all right all right
what does it say uh zaka inen says no
matter the impossible choice no one gets
out of this alive love the con love this
conversation it was good it was good in
the end we all will meet our maker
all right and maybe even next process
yeah Lex McCormick says you three
Christian men how can I hear God I am
lost but seeking and am met with silence
other Christians tell me that evil seeks
signs and wonders I hope I'm not evil
but I do wish God would speak to me so
that I might know him as my priest said
once in the introduction to a book an
evil generation looks for signs and
wonders but a stupid generation ignores
signs and wonders and they are there the
Christian view of the world is rich in
symbolism but you're not gonna you're
not gonna be hearing a you know a voice
come out of the sky probably uh you know
anytime soon so maybe you will I don't
know but where can you hear the word of
God well I've got two really simple
answers they're not going to sound cool
and mystical uh go to church and read
the Bible that would be a good place to
and pray that would be a good place I
just I just want to point out that I
just I just think the idea that there is
some greater power that created
everything that there's some kind of
purpose to all this and that there are
signs for us to see is is completely
absurd what makes more sense is that an
advanced species created all of them
this for some purpose and that we're
here for a reason and there are signs in
the system like a a god-like species
you know or something or like you make a
great point
we love talking about may I say
something to that last question because
it's such an important question and I
always like to point out that if you
read The Narrative of the gospels Christ
went through the Galilee and drove out
all disease that says that he went from
Village to Village and healed everyone
and this was his ministry for several
years it culminates uh in the events
that precede Palm Sunday last week with
the raising of Lazarus from the dead he
literally speaks into the tomb and calls
forth uh Lazarus who's been dead uh four
days it in the in the presence of people
who believe in him and people who don't
believe in him and no one contested
these miracles in fact it says that the
the high priest I referenced this line
earlier but without context that the
high priest himself said after that
essentially it's better that one man
should die for the nation that that in
other words that began to plot to kill
Jesus not because they didn't believe in
the Miracles but because they did I say
all of that to say even people who
literally heard God speak people who
literally stood in the presence of God's
son and watched him call forth the dead
to life didn't believe and so I
understand the desperation of of
non-belief and I understand the longing
that is in in the human heart to hear
God directly that you might believe in
him but it is a mistaken View
if you did hear from God there is
absolutely no certainty that you would
believe and so the better thing to
realize I think is that what God values
most highly is Faith and faith is the
substance of things not seen things not
heard things hoped for and so in many
ways it's a great gift from God that we
don't see and hear from him and that
instead we're left with the opportunity
to put faith in him which is an
unsatisfied it's an even more
unsatisfying answer than read the Bible
and go to church
Until you realize the beauty of it that
it is in faith that we can be saved and
not in certainty and and uh in that way
it's it is quite a a gift from God that
we don't always hear his voice or see
his face all right our our strike says
Tim when I ask if you change your mind
on possible fraud of Republicans if
Republicans lost midterms you dismissed
it and I felt disrespected it was a
sincere question I did not dismiss it
um I have I I'm sorry you felt that way
what my point was
in 2018 I was adamant Republicans were
going to win and win big and then they
didn't I didn't assume it was because it
was cheated I assumed it was because I
was wrong if in November the Republicans
lose I'm going to assume it's because
I'm wrong if evidence emerges of direct
actions
I will consider all evidence so the
challenge I have especially with like
2020 is
we we get stories about the campaigns
run by Democrat politicians the deals
they cut with Republicans uh voter in
the park the universal mail-in bouts
that was recently ruled unconstitutional
in Pennsylvania and I say all of that is
just actual politics that resulted in a
shadow campaign that saved the elections
the best way you can call it I've not
seen evidence of watermarked ballots or
or you know overt fraud to a degree
where I'm convinced that's the issue at
hand so even though I I really do
believe Republicans are on track to win
especially considering every poll and
every outcry from democrats for one
there are many variables from now until
today which I can't predict and two it's
possible I'm not omniscient yeah it's
just possible it's back to Occam's razor
right yeah and I think this is right I
say of 2020 I think that there's there's
abundant evidence that the election was
rigged
there is not enough evidence that it was
stolen and those are incredibly distinct
real quick just to make sure we clarify
that rigged in the sense that lawmakers
got together a year in advance they
passed new laws yes uh voter like we
mentioned the media literally suppressed
stories that would be harmful to their
preferred candidate right and in that
way it's like the the referees uh were
only calling strikes on one side uh it
would be like if if uh Jonathan and
Isaac Jonathan Isaac and I played a game
of one-on-one that is a rigged game
right I I am an a I am at a pronounced
disadvantage going into it that you can
say that it is unfair but it isn't
cheating at that point that he makes all
the points this is an important
distinction there was a piece published
in RealClearPolitics uh not too long ago
from a very serious guy who had worked
with the Department of Justice on
Election issues and he he believes that
there is evidence hard evidence of
actual stolen ballots in certain States
and he he leaves the conclusion vague as
to what the this means for the overall
election but that would be say one piece
of evidence of the sort you're looking
for but to your point Jeremy is that
sufficient to do what in the political
process how is that going to overrule an
election and and the question of rigging
and outright stealing oh there there's a
distinction and like you Tim I'm open to
the I've seen some evidence even using
geo location type data that is fairly
compelling that there was some cheating
going on I'm open to the idea that an
election is still in you just have to
you have to prove it I I think there's
two big things at play and I think
people don't want to believe them one is
that I off I told this to Steve Bannon I
said I know people who are as dumb as a
box of rocks with no business in
politics they couldn't tell you who Ruth
Bader Ginsburg was they don't know how
many justices there are and they post
videos of themselves voting they took
away sports they took away video games
they took away movies they locked people
in their homes and told you it was
Trump's fault and I saw people that
never got political in my life with
nothing else to do getting political
yeah we saw what happened in
Pennsylvania they ruled this rule this
this Universal mail-in voting
unconscious institutional I'm like dude
it all happened above board I think you
just don't want to accept it that for a
year Republicans actually were working
against Republicans it's also when
people say you believe that more people
turned out to vote for Joe Biden than
Barack Obama and it's like no they
didn't have to turn out they legal they
lawfully changed the nature of the of uh
the election to instead of having to go
stand in a line you had to check your
mail so of course when you make it that
easy there are going to be more votes
that's why they wanted it and it makes
it harder for uh it's an advantage for
Democrats because of urban density
compared to the the disparate nature of
rural uh environments which are more
Republican but we've gone a little bit
over and we got to do this point out the
problem of tallying votes by with a
corporation behind the scenes and people
that people aren't transparently allowed
to witness is a code red problem with
our elections we need to see every vote
on some sort of public database so we
can verify our systems I agree so with
that my friends if you haven't already
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and head over to timcast.com because
we're gonna have that members only
segment going up at about 11 p.m and
you'll not want to miss it we'll make it
extra spicy you can follow me at timcast
uh you can follow the show at timcastirl
Smokey Mike and the god king do you guys
want to shout anything out
I'd like to remind people that the book
speechless coming out of the paperback
head over to Amazon.com buy yours today
that's true and if you want to be
hairless you should go to
ihateairies.com and get a brand new
razor it's the best razor out there on
the market and you can do that right
after you get speechless controlling
words controlling mines anybody else I
mean if you hate being hairy razors are
perfect I'm Sheamus [ __ ] and I have a
channel called Freedom Tunes check it
out the video we just released is one
that I'm very proud of so and I really
think you guys will enjoy it I'm Ian
cross and you guys can follow my friends
on Twitter at the real daily wire that
is the real daily wire on Twitter and I
love you so much thank you thank you
guys all very much for tuning in this
has been one of my favorite episodes
today I think I love the philosophical
conversations and the Deep profound
conundrums we make up for ourselves and
try to reason through you guys may
follow me on Twitter at Sarah patchlands
also minds.com and I also have sourpatch
lids.me we will see you all at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys